so we have reports now that
israel has launched a ground invasion of
gaza there are numerous reports stating
this to be the case
however there are now conflicting
reports coming out claiming that israel
has not invaded gaza and
hey this is how war goes called fog of
war for a reason
but even though there have been some
statements put out by the idf that they
have not invaded gaza
there are still numerous outlets
asserting and repeating
no they did so it's hard to know exactly
what's going on
other than over the past several days it
has been an escalating conflict
and uh i don't think we have a strong
enough administration to deal with it
which is leading to these conflicts
plus you know you you'll probably hear
from a lot of conservative commentators
biden resumed funding to some of these
palestinian groups
and then all of a sudden rockets start
firing up now we're seeing brawls in the
streets
there's a really brutal video of uh what
appears to be a jewish man being just
covered in blood
because he had words with a
pro-palestinian group and they they beat
the crap out of them
so things are getting crazy people are
are taking this stuff extremely
seriously
and uh you know we'll get into all that
we also have news the cdc has announced
that
if you are fully vaccinated you no
longer have to wear a mask which was
confusing to people in red states
because
they already don't have to even at where
we are they lifted the mass
mandates of masked they've already
announced the end of the mask mandates
so i don't know what joe biden's doing
but he puts out a tweet like
he's like here's the deal you either get
the the vaccine or you wear mask that's
it and everyone's like
shut up idiot he's only talking to like
new york basically
so we're gonna get into all of this and
joining us today is filmmaker and now
uh you are a congressional candidate
robbie starbuck yep thank you so much
for having me yeah
you want to give a brief introduction
who you are what you do yeah so i
started out as a filmmaker i've directed
oscar winning actors actresses some of
the biggest music stars in the world
and i came out as a republican in 2015
and endorsed trump
and i knew that that would burn down my
career it did and i'm running for
congress now
right on we got ian chilling oh hello
everyone ian crossland here thanks
happy to be here robbie great to meet
you man great to meet you too and i'm in
the corner pushing buttons i'm really
looking forward to tonight's
conversation because robbie's a great
conversationalist
but before we get started head over to
timcast.com and become
a member to get access to exclusive
members only segment there's a big
blue members only button you just click
that and you can see you can sign up
with striper paypal
and then in the members area you can
actually get access to this
huge library of content tons of
interviews six
pages of just all of these different
interviews you get access to and i will
also mention we have a
free bonus segment that is already up
from yesterday
it is dave smith and ian talking about
the federal reserve that is free if you
go to the members
area you can watch it for free but do
sign up because in the event that we get
banned which is increasingly likely
considering what's going on
this is where you'll be able to find the
content and with your support as members
will be able to keep producing content
otherwise
the reality is we get funded based on
like ads
on youtube and things like that so if we
ever did get banned then it's like how
do you pay the bills well because of the
member program we are now
secure and have that safety net so make
sure you become a member but also don't
forget to like share subscribe
hit that notification bell if you're
listening on itunes spotify give us a
good review give us five stars
and if you're on youtube whatever take
the url post it to twitter post it to
facebook that is the most powerful thing
you can do to help the show
it is really appreciated let's get into
this first massive breaking story
of which i will first admit i know a
decent amount
but there's so much conflicting
information about israel and palestine
depending on who you ask
they will tell you you're lying it's
misinformation and depending on which
source you read they'll give you
conflicting information
there's some big hubbub right now
because some celebrity put out this meme
where it was like
israel are just colonists who are
stealing land
depending on where you go you can get
you can get a fist in the face
based on what you're saying but i i
gotta be honest i think we know which
direction typically
is the one going to be throwing those
punches and it's going to be the the
left-wing groups
and i just want to point out right so
the big news is that israel true
israeli troops have entered gaza again
there's conflicting information
we'll get into this stuff i'm just
confused right off the bat
how leftist groups are very much in
support of of
you know of palestine and gaza when
their ideology is just not allowed in
these places
but isn't that weird you know what i
mean oh it's absolutely weird but
you know it's sort of like in war you
make alliances
with unlikely friends you know and
that's what they've done
because at it at their core you know
marxism
and this sort of islamist jihadists over
there in hamas
they were aligned and wanting to destroy
the west and they're very anti-israel
did you did you see what happened in
birmingham in the uk
where the the school wanted to do an
lgbt curriculum
and then the muslims came out and like
women in like niqab were protesting
and it was just crazy there was a like
there was a gay guy saying like we're
fighting for you and they're like get
out of here and they were insulting him
and using slurs
it's crazy stuff i don't want to derail
too much let's let me pull this up we
got the washington post here all right
the washington post says it's true
israeli troops have crossed into the
gaza strip
the israeli military said early friday
as artillery tanks and warplanes joined
in a withering assault on the
palestinian enclave
and the israeli military readied at
least three brigades of troops for
action
raising the prospect of an all-out
ground invasion just after midnight the
israeli military announced that air and
ground forces had joined in an attack on
gaza
but a military spokesman did not detail
the number or type of troops that had
crossed the border
for most of thursday the air war between
israelis and palestinians had raged
unabated
with casualties uh continuing to climb
on both sides amid rocket fire and
airstrikes so
i we saw a story where i guess first
israel wiped out a bunch of hamas
commanders
then we heard hamas was like okay okay
we're done and then i was like nah
and then hamas was like all right then
fired a bunch more rockets
have you been following this i have been
and i think i think the first part of it
you know where this all starts is
they always use the propaganda of
children as human shields
and that's how you get to this point is
that you know
they like to pretend that israel is
doing what they're doing with
settlements for no reason
you know in the west bank in the west
bank and so so what's the reason for it
i think the real reason is historically
you know hamas and groups like them they
wanted to push
jews into a part of israel that was
really only nine miles wide and
that's from sea to foothill and the
reason for that was because they could
essentially trap them into an area where
they were very vulnerable and could
you know take gaza yeah well here's
here's the idea though
is that those areas they used as places
to bring weapons
and so those weapons could be used on
the jews in israel and now arabs and
israel as well
and so protecting that point was very
important and it was something that
has been you know a core in terms of the
idf's ideology in israel's ideology
since the six day war
and so it's an important part of
maintaining their security for their
citizens which is their you know of
utmost importance and if i was
running israel same sort of thing you
got to keep your people safe so i think
that's
they're protecting to make sure that
weapons don't get into those areas
so there there's a video that's going
viral where this uh palestinian and i
think he's in the west bank is being
interviewed
and he basically says that the israelis
are coming and claiming they have the
right to the buildings to the property
and they're they're they're uh they're
calling it an eviction when they have no
legal claim to any of this land anyway
and they're slowly removing palestinians
from the west bank so this went viral
because
you know the cnn lady was like how do
you know how do you respond to you know
they're saying that you're
these are evictions and the guy was like
do you support the displacement of my
people
so what's going on here i mean i don't
know if you're i don't think you're an
expert on this or anything no not
entirely but i do know a good deal about
the history and so essentially
you know i think there's also people who
state claims to that same land who are
jewish that you know essentially like
who's going to be the court for that
who's going to decide which is which and
the other thing people have to keep in
mind is hamas uses
what looks like normal people and
emotional situations as a weapon
so in those areas if you see a video of
a crying child and it's 10 seconds long
and then there's a post along with it
says this kid's crying because an
israeli soldier just did whatever to
their dad
there's no proof of that actually
happening but they use that all the time
you know a hamas
um you know news outlet just put out
that
if you see rockets coming don't film it
from your windows please
you shouldn't be able to see those
rockets from your windows there's
there's a meme
where it's uh there's you know you know
the npc meme
yeah like the so there's there's an npc
guy and i guess you weren't in my head
or something and he's like
israel has a right to defend itself and
the regular guy says so does palestine
and then it shows the npc pause and then
get angry and i'm like well
hold on hold on uh who fired the rockets
first
who who who's which which which side was
it palestine or was it israel that fire
far back you're gonna go
no no you gotta talk about right now
like a week ago
yeah you fired the rockets first hamas
so so who's defending who
yep israel how is it self-defense when
they fire a bunch of rockets into
civilian areas because they're under
siege
where in in the west bank because
because people in the west bank are
being kicked out of their houses
they don't have access to fresh water
they they can only be outside certain
hours
so across military checkpoints okay so
because there's
a conflict in the west bank hamas in
gaza fires rockets into various cities
and civilian areas
it's messed up that's that's that's
that's okay so there's a reason that's
they call it terrorism
because in war typically you target
military targets or when you have a
conflict in the west bank the conflict
is in the west bank
for them to fire rockets
indiscriminately all throughout israel
to me i just look at that and i'm like i
understand like if i
had had land and it was being you know
taken over whatever you know
settled i'd be upset too but i don't see
how you win a war by firing rockets
indiscriminately into like schools and
buses and civilian areas and not only
that they set it up
so that when israel does respond to 300
rockets come from places in a
residential area where they're firing
them off when israel responds
innocent people die so kids die and they
do that because at the end of the day
those kids are not kids to them they
don't see them as innocent beautiful
little human beings they see them as
weapons and shields
so they know that in the media
especially in the western media if you
have that headline that two kids died
that that is an emotional it even i mean
it it hurts everybody who
who you know has a harp because they're
kids but they do that intentionally
because they know that's going to be the
case that's why that news story came out
saying don't film us shooting rockets
from outside your window
why are you outside the windows of
normal people shooting rockets it's it's
really hard to figure out what's going
on too because
i don't speak the language and you see
these propaganda videos and from both
sides right there'll be a video of a guy
and he's speaking arabic and then
you know i watched one video where
there's a guy on the phone yelling and
it was from a pro-israel
uh commentator saying this is a warning
that israel has
has called the guy and said that there
are there are rockets being fired from
your building you need to get everyone
out because in one hour
we're gonna fire a knock bomb it's gonna
you know shock the building
and then i don't know that's true
because i can't understand a word that's
being said yeah but i can tell you
like i mentioned before fire rockets
indiscriminately
there there was a meme i saw and then i
think i think it's fair and i i think
it's fair to bring up
if if israel laid down all of its arms
right now the iron dome defense system
what do you think would happen they'd be
wiped out yeah they'd probably overrun
and if palestine if the if gaza laid
down their opens what do you think would
happen
well they basically have except for the
militant terrorist groups or the
i mean that's the group though always
that has arms
you know and and the problem is is that
normal people
they're not doing anything to say oh
this we don't accept this
they're accepting of that's the
situation and that they run things
you know not that look i i saw videos
where the rockets are being fired by
hamas
and people are yeah they're cheering
they're cheering for it i
i understand right if i was in an area
and i believed it was my land
look the problem is both sides are going
to claim they're right they have moral
superiority for whatever reason
and i from the outside i'm trying to
assess what do we do right now to stop
the pain and suffering and death of
destruction
and i see people cheering for rockets
being fired indiscriminately into
civilian areas
and i'm like i understand the idf uh
does airstrikes and surgical strikes
which also hit civilian areas
but israel didn't fire the rockets first
yeah you can go back at six day war in
egypt and sign up you know all that
stuff
right now everybody's chilling there's
tensions everybody's been fighting
they've been fighting for a long time
and then all sudden you see this video
of just rockets flying through the air
and then you see the aftermath because
the iron dome can't intercept every
single one
and i've i've talked to people who i
i've met a skateboarder
who was from gaza who talked to me about
a whole bunch of stuff and it was really
interesting
and his perspective was was really
nuanced he was like the problem is it's
a war with
both sides asserting moral superiority
and he was like my family decided to
leave and he was fortunate enough to get
out
and then i've met people in israel who
are like i don't know
why i don't get it i don't know all i
know is that one day a rocket exploded
above my apartment and i was terrified
so we're this has been going on for so
long
it's it's got to the point where let me
use another another place as an example
the uh belfast
they ever been to belfast no northern
ireland ireland yeah so
they have something called the peace
wall so it's it's crazy what was going
on in northern ireland not the same
thing but
i remember when i was there and i was
being shown around by this by this dude
he and on on the one side of the peace
wall it's like free palestine
and i was like yeah and go figure it's
like a leftist thing on the other side
it said pro-israel and i was like
why are people in in what is this this
is this is belfast
and what the dude they said to me was
it's tribal it's it's been so ingrained
the hatred between each side
that they don't really care as to what's
causing the fight the fight is here the
fight is real
and they want to wipe the other side out
so i understand someone's going to go
back and be like the crimes of this you
know the crimes of that
it's like well what can we do right now
because y'all just can't be mad at each
other forever there's got to be
something we can do
and we can start by not firing rockets
yeah well i ask people too you know when
it comes to the civilians getting hurt
the question people need to ask is if
hamas was firing rockets at israel from
a military base or from a field
somewhere where would israel be dropping
their bombs they'd be dropping them on
the field exactly
but hamas is choosing to make those
strikes on purpose in civilian areas
where they don't have military assets
they're not trying to hit an israeli
military asset they're trying to hit
normal people look
do you see that i'm sorry man i'm i'm
just i'm done playing these games
i i'm not gonna pretend to know the full
history of israel-palestine i know
a bit about it but that woman posted
earlier
uh it was israel but the whole thing was
flowers and said palestine
then you had that other guy remember
that guy who was working for bernie or
whatever who
said something about driving them out to
the sea or whatever do you remember that
i knew what you're talking about like
these people are like no no we believe
in peace
and then they start chanting to drive
the jews into the sea or whatever and
i'm like
i don't believe you man that goes back
to the nine-mile thing that i was
talking about at that narrowest point
that's they want they want them to be in
the narrowest possible vulnerable
position
i'm sorry the the thing that was being
chanted was like free palestine
from the whatever river to the state
from the river to the sea
it's a song and then you had that woman
again it's like it's israel and
it just says palestine and there's
flowers everywhere and people are like
dude we get what you're saying you want
israel destroyed they don't want it
there
and i'm sorry but like you can go back
to the 60s and say
we have problems with all this you can
go back to the the the
the european powers and they're dividing
up plans and all that bro
i wasn't alive back then i don't know
about the sins of the father whatever
all i know is like can we stop the
fighting somehow
we can uh this is the theocracy is what
concerns me
in the united states we've got the
freedom of religion which is amazing
because
you can have coexisting cultures and
religions and we all get along for the
most part but
in israel and palestine it's it's
different cultures and religions and
languages and because of that
have you ever been to israel there's mad
conflict no you can you
i've had lots of arabs and and i i've
been there and it's
like cosmopolitan urban metro it was
like you walk around people are
i've been to i've been to egypt and
morocco and i have seen
the theocratic rule i i was uh there's a
casino in the hilton of egypt
and i was hanging out with this egyptian
guy and i was like you want to hit up
the casino he goes oh i can't it's
illegal
yeah and i was like what he's like you
can and i was like huh
he's like yeah yeah it's only only
people who are muslim if you're egyptian
you're not allowed to go to the casino
it's illegal
but for everyone else it's legal and i'm
like wow all right i went to casino and
it was foreigners hanging out inside
i go to i went to israel and it was like
hanging out in boston or whatever yeah
it was like
very urban metro
liberal morocco is the same thing i've
been to morocco same thing where like
they don't accept
any outside thought or culture at all i
mean it's very narrow in terms of what
they're okay with
yep and so that's like if you want to
see that that's where that is
i think i think israel is technically a
jewish state right yes
so whereas the united states isn't a
christian state we're a we don't have a
national
i mean it's we don't have a national
religion but i think if you went back
and you said okay what is the
core you know sort of basis in terms of
like fundamental morality in our country
it would go back to judeo-christian
values 100
but that's sort of the beauty of freedom
of religion here is we don't say hey you
have to believe this but they also don't
say in israel you have to believe this
it's just so happens you know they're
they're very forward in terms of the
fact that this is a home
for jewish people you know and i think
that that's it's it's different than us
but it's no less accepting of outside
belief system judaism is a very
interesting religion because it's
it's a religion and a culture and it's
the only religion i think on earth
that's also a culture like you mean your
mother you mean an ethnicity
yes it's an ethnicity and a religion if
your mother was jewish then you're
jewish or and you can go get
become a jew by going to like a rabbi
and worship the real so it's
and it's that's that's converting it it
can that it concerns me not that it's a
good or a bad thing it's not
that but i think it's it's so ingrained
in who these people are
who a jew is is that you don't have to
practice judaism
in israel and they're fairly secular
right it's it's
it's fairly remarkable for the middle
east to be honest
i had a question um from my
understanding it sounds to me like
israel is the only country in that part
of the world that
is okay with uh like homosexuality and
that kind of thing is this correct they
don't throw people off buildings
or anything like that i mean people have
their own private belief systems you
know and that's
it's sort of similar to the united
states in that regard like i mean it's
kind of
somewhat live and let live even if i
have different opinions than you or i
don't
like this like they're not going to go
and try to hurt the person
you know another thing to keep in mind
too is like israel wasn't the one trying
to
you know put all these and impose all
these sanctions on everybody if you look
at the surrounding countries and say
how many of them have a ban on somebody
with an israeli passport from being able
to travel
it's the majority of them right don't
let anybody even it's other uh
muslim nations too yeah i think i'm not
entirely sure but doesn't indonesia have
something similar
in terms of banning them yeah if you
have if you haven't if you have a lot of
them a lot of the
the islamic nations do not allow people
with israeli passports even if they
don't live there if even if they have
another
you know passport from another country
they won't let you in if you have a code
nationality so
this is something that they they talk
about when uh you're doing international
journalism
if you go to israel and you get a stamp
on your passport
you are banned from a whole bunch of
countries and so there's two things you
can do
you can get what's called a dupe
duplicate passport and you literally go
to the us government and say
i need a passport to go to israel and
they give you a very like it's like a
very temporary one it's good for like a
year
and that's the one you use for going to
israel that way you have your other
passport you can go to the other
countries uh but what israel started
doing was they were instead of stamping
passports they were giving
uh visa cards that they would put in the
passport and then
you wouldn't get a stamp because they
knew that people
don't view them as legitimate and you
can't go to a ton of countries
and we're not talking about just the
middle east i'm pretty sure it was like
either indonesia or malaysia or
something
there's countries in africa too same
thing right but the one thing they all
have in common is that their
islamic governments you know where
they're explicitly so actually you know
what
the jewish religion would not be the
only one that is also a culture and all
those things you know islam is too in
fact islam is to a much greater degree
in terms of
how many countries are like that well
it's not ethnicity
you know what i mean yeah that's that's
definitely you can be ethnically jewish
and not religious but you can be
you can be a religious lead that's why
it's culture it's a it
has its own culture entirely that turns
into like a nationalism of its own
sort of making you know you know i just
uh
when i when i look at the whole
situation i think
one thing that the left is correct about
is that
israel has the military support of the
west and because of that they're in a
dominant position
and i'm like i look at that and think to
myself
it's a war that's been going on for a
long time and whose side are you on
i don't live there i don't know i know
the u.s provides support technically for
both
factions you know biden do you know do
you know who he was providing funding to
i know ben shapiro was tweeting about it
yep he was giving funding
to essentially to hamas because he's
giving it to palestine
and we all know what happens when you
give money to them i think it's on
purpose it's it happens oh
well i mean where were all of these
rockets while trump was president
right because this didn't happen i think
you know
i think it's on purpose i think in order
to justify military expansion in the
middle east they need conflict
they need to say oh no oh geez oh
israel's in danger so we better bring
out more troops we better have more
occupation
and so surprise surprise money starts
flowing into palestine as soon as joe
biden's back in in the rockets start
flying
and then we provide the support for
israel so i'm not
i'm not saying i know that to be a fact
i'm saying that seems to be a plausible
idea in my book
that we the military industrial complex
wants occupation in various countries
iraq and afghanistan particularly
because we know they want to go into
iran
we know they want syria for access to
the pipeline you need conflict to
justify it i'm not even going to say
that this is what i believe but false
flags are real
and if a country fakes it and says we
just got attacked by another country but
they did it to themselves
and then that gives them justification
for a ground invasion that's happened in
the past
i don't think that's i don't know but i
don't think it happened i don't think
i'm just pointed out
when you when you look at the set of
facts in terms of
the invasion of iraq afghanistan the
mainstream media lying to us you can see
the establishment very very much
wants to be occupying these places there
was a report that came out in the
guardian
that the u.s was planning on entering
syria well before the syrian civil war
why
the qatar turkey pipeline competing with
russian natural gas in ukraine by
sending up a pipeline
through syria and turkey but assad said
no all of a sudden
war breaks out the u.s says now's our
chance conflict erupts
the u.s wants to occupy these places
donald trump comes in
and he says no new wars and they start
yelling at him donald trump says i want
the troops out of syria they lied to him
and they lied to us to keep
troops in syria then trump says pull the
troops out of afghanistan and they
said no and they wouldn't do it they
defied donald trump they defy what the
will of the people was
because they want to be there now i
think they will do everything in their
power to have that justification for
doing it
joe biden literally is providing funding
to palestinian groups
and then within a few months rockets
start flying through the air
i'm not saying it it's a fact i'm not
saying i have evidence of this i'm just
saying it would not surprise me
if the administration if biden the
democrats were alike how can we get more
conflict to justify military presence in
the middle east
well we can provide funding to certain
groups that will result in conflict and
chaos
that's what the cia did with the
mujahideen now as we've seen
they learn their lesson though here's
the thing like at a certain point they
have to learn their lesson we all
understand there was no wmds
okay so if you really wised up say
you're pretending you're them
it doesn't really make as much sense to
coordinate some kind of false flag or a
lie through the media
it would make a whole lot more sense to
just hand the money over to a group that
wants to bomb somebody else
this is this is the big secret about
conspiracy theories people
think like the journalists are working
for the ca ooh
operation you know mockingbird or
whatever it was called and uh
that's not how it works these leftist
news organizations
they don't hire a journalist and say and
now you'll report the lies we tell you
hahaha
they find some activists and say you're
good at what you do would you like to be
a journalist
and then they bring activists on
activists who don't care
for reporting they care for politics and
they espouse the politics of the
political
uh in the the politics of the individual
who runs the company
yeah 100 that's so so you don't need
to hire an assassin you don't need to
hire the sh the shills you find people
who are already predisposed to certain
behaviors and you fund them to
exacerbate whatever it is they're doing
well and look at step two to who else
did we give money to
iran you know they're the next domino
here
now we're firing warning shots at them
and yeah but we gave them money
there was conflict with trump you know
yeah in iran before this too
so i think the us the idea is that if we
leave the middle east
as a power vacuum taliban will come in
terror groups will come in
isis will come back or something
equivalent to it or russia and china
will come in
so we have to be there how do we justify
being there american people don't want
to be there
the american people are like we don't
want to waste money sending our our men
and women in uniform overseas for this
stuff
and then some bombs go flying and
there's a conflict and people are
fighting in the streets and then it's
like oh now we got to stay well at what
point do we ask ourselves though what
were they doing before we went there
were these groups fighting with each
other killing each other back then
so where has it gotten us having our
people get killed there
well i mean here's the here's the here's
the big challenge i suppose
why are if that's if the issue is
america first why is america getting
involved in
is israel's politics as it is and just
saying have at it i would say
that the reason there is strategically
aligning ourselves with something that
keeps us safer too because that whole
area
if there's nothing deterring them from
being able to go and turn their fire say
they destroy israel and we
we just do nothing and we allow that to
happen well they have to turn the anger
and all of the things that they've
enacted out on israel onto somebody else
and in general the thing they hate the
most after that is the west in general i
will
so i will say in that sense it's this
strategic ally if
if there is a real argument for the the
power vacuum in the middle east
and we are invading countries because of
it
i think that's wrong if the alternative
is israel is literally there and we can
provide support to make sure they're
safe and secure that's a big difference
that's very different from invading a
bunch of others exactly and that's where
i stand is
let's make sure that they have the
ability to exist because they should be
allowed to exist
and make sure they're safe but i don't
want to be in any of these places
anymore
they've been doing this for thousands of
years it will continue for thousands of
years and i don't want americans to die
as part of that
math equation have you seen that there's
a video i think it's called like this
uh this land is my land god made this
land for me and it's an animation
showing all of the different groups that
have been fighting over the holy land
for thousands of years
and it's like it's it's one song and
it's
like every time the new person comes in
and tramples over the next group i've
seen that they're singing
the same song and it just goes back and
forth with every single i haven't seen
this
it's it's like this this conflict will
never end
because everybody is like it was
historically my land and they're like
yeah but if you go back even further it
was mine
well even further it was mine don't
don't discount the possibility that
israel may try to actually end this
in terms of with hamas because they know
that biden's going to be paralyzed right
now because
if biden steps in and does anything that
is anti-israel at this point
it will confirm everything that has been
said about the democratic party for the
past six years
that they're anti-israel and that they
are not friendly to the jewish people
and if he does that that's going to
create a whole host of other issues well
we
we we just saw this story biden
basically defended israel uh
he literally defended israel he says
that there hasn't been a significant
overreaction
as idf bombards gaza and troops mass on
border
yeah biden is paralyzed he doesn't have
he doesn't have the ability to be strong
and firm
it's just not within him he's gonna
stumble and mutter in his words and fall
asleep halfway through
so if anything we could discount any you
know conspiracy theories about military
industrial complexes or whatever fine
but it could very well just be that
hamas is like
trump's gone green light yeah because
bai ain't gonna do anything about it and
then israel is like
well we're gonna we're gonna strike back
and what's biden gonna do about it
exactly and at this point israel may be
making the calculation why not go and do
all this the irony in all of this
is that for the left who pretends to
care about the palestinians
trump was the best president for them
because he was able to keep the whole
house in order
because you almost had this like you
know this chaotic energy
all the time that was keeping everybody
on their toes there so
if anybody got out of line he was able
to step in and be like well if you do
this it's gonna happen and they don't
know what kind of wild card he's gonna
throw at them look that's the difference
with biden they both know he's paralyzed
exactly
look at the abraham accords you had
these arabic nations signing these peace
treaties and these deals and these
economic ties with israel
and no explosions yep
but you know what that's why i was
saying that's bad for the
military-industrial complex that's bad
for the establishment that wants
gas pipelines and then it's really funny
because i think it was i don't know if
it was i don't know if it was jack who
pointed this out but
they shut down the uh gretchen whitmer
in
in michigan wants to shut down this oil
pipeline it's dangerous it's dangerous
the colonial pipeline hack they shut
down keystone we went from being energy
independent to energy dependent yep
very quickly and it provides another
excuse
to have a presence in the middle east
100 we talked about this just like
couple hours ago we were saying
that essentially you know we need to get
to the point as a nation this is part of
being anti-war we need to be energy
independent because
if we're not then we need to be worried
about every time an oil field gets
captured by a terror group or gets
burned by a terror group
we were in advice under trump where if
that happened it wasn't such a big
problem for us unless you're investing
in oil you know in the stock market but
for american people at the gas pump it
wasn't a big problem because we were
energy independent enough to deal with
whatever came outside there because we
had enough here
with biden you don't it's it's awfully
convenient for
those who wanted to keep our military in
syria yeah i remember when uh trump
wanted to pull out of syria
and then they basically were like but
the oil so trump says okay fine
we're keeping in just enough troops to
get the oil and he just blurts it out
it was really funny because the anti-war
left is continually like
trump's admitting exactly what the us is
doing yeah and
they don't get it trump was admitting it
on purpose he doesn't want
trump did not want to be there trump
didn't care about it all trump cared
about was america america first energy
independent bring our jobs back make
america great again
he didn't care about being in syria so
when they were like we're not going to
pull our troops out
trump was like why because they're
guarding oil trump said then get
everyone else out and guard the oil and
then he goes on tv and says don't worry
we still have all their oil
and everyone like don't you appreciate
he's pulled the curtain back
he's breaking the fourth wall and
telling you exactly what this is this is
all theater
to distract you from what's really going
on this is what's really going on so if
that's what they want here they can have
that but we're not going to do this
remember remember when trump was
standing outside like by the helicopter
or whatever
and he's like we're doing a great
weapons deal with saudi arabia it's
going to be great for our economy we're
going to make billions of dollars giving
weapons to this country
and the anti-war left was just like he
he just admitted at all he just came out
and said it
they actually that was the beauty of
trump though you know in so many ways
and and i think that it's something
we're going to see again when he comes
out and do
does these rallies but he was just so
transparent
about all these things and in a weird
way
so much of our country was not ready for
that transparency because
they were conditioned you know through
many different things but you know just
this exposure effect by itself of your
whole life being exposed to people who
lie to you
right having this person just blurt out
the truth all the time
sounds crazy lied about weird stupid
things a lot but like the important
stuff he would just
blurt out the truth and people were so
conditioned to having people in
positions of power lie to them
that that was like just an earthquake
this was how you could tell the agenda
of trump was
was uh was legitimate he would lie about
things
when he would lie about something you
knew was something he actually cared
about domestic policy or
his character and then he would be
openly just like oh yeah we're getting
the oil and we want to pull everybody
else out and
we're selling weapons to these countries
he didn't care about that he didn't want
to keep doing it it meant nothing to him
so he had no problem telling people
because it wasn't part of his agenda
yeah the things he was lying about like
yeah stormy daniel stuff
or just like ego stuff number of people
number of people at his rallies it were
things that directly impacted
his his his mission agenda and stature
in the united states
and it's i there's the intercept said
that he was the simultaneously the most
honest and the most
deceitful president we've ever had
because on these really important issues
he would just like open his mouth and
tell you everything
well the thing that they you know they
never honestly actually talk about is
that he's an entertainer
he's not a politician and when you're an
entertainer you're a storyteller when
you tell stories things are naturally
going to kind of get a little bit
grandiose you know and i think that to
some degree
people need to have common sense and
understand that you know yeah
yeah i will say too when when he had the
inauguration
and he was like there was more people
who watched this than any other group
and the media was like that's a lie that
what they do is these clever tricks
where
trump says we had the biggest
inauguration ever the media then goes
there were only you know 50 000 people
at
in in dc which is which which means
trump lied
and it's like did trump say only in
attendance
or was he referring to all viewership
online in
in general yeah and so they they always
make the assumption in the most
in the worst possible way to make it
look like he's lying or being
manipulative
that was that's what the media did the
whole time and i got that's the story of
his presidency
that's right the story of the presidency
now we're now we got joe biden
and i just got to say it's really funny
because i honestly didn't think
we would all be so spot on you know all
of the
like i don't want to say necessarily say
conservative but democrat critical or
establishment critical personalities
be it the disaffected liberals or the
conservatives we're like joe biden's
going to have a radical left policy
agenda it's going to cause more war gas
prices are going to skyrocket the riots
are going to continue
and i mean i genuinely thought that
would happen but i kind of felt like we
wouldn't be
like five for five i thought it would
take six months
that's the thing i didn't know it would
be this fast he's like i mean
he's like on some sort of weird kind of
failure speed i didn't know they made it
but
he's doing speed balls for failure
because he's just like a rocket and in
every other way he's like asleep
i know you know remember that quote from
joe biden i mentioned the other day
where he was like
i can't remember exactly what it was but
he goes the one thing that you gotta
do you know to be great and when when
you're
it's uh anyway
everyone did that yeah he was like
anyway anyway so i'll move on you guys
want me to move on
here i'll tell you what i think's
happening biden comes out and he's all
like you know shaking and confused and
it's you know they're like what's your
plan better calf care
and then all the democrats are just
clapping and cheering for it yeah and
all the conservatives like the dude's
insane he's off his rocker
his brain isn't working and then he goes
i'm gonna get in trouble if i take
questions so i'm gonna
get out of here he walks backstage and
he's like where's jill and then he goes
stands up straight he goes
we're done moving forward i want
hyperinflation we're going to decimate
this economy we're going to drop
consumerism climate change is a very
serious problem
now over here i want more more
immigrants coming to the border so
resend trump's orders
and we're going to reopen these
facilities we want to create chaos
ladies and gentlemen get the job done
and get me another 50 million of bitcoin
at least you think he's a bumbling fool
but i'll put it this way i'm not saying
this is true
i'm just saying at a certain point the
failures
how could you be in terms of like policy
positions in four months
0 and 5. like the riots are still
happening inflation is getting worse
these are his policy positions they're
dropping the charges on antifa
he's giving out more money for people
not to work he's rescinded trump's
executive orders he's reopened the
migrant facilities
he's funding these palestinian groups
how could that be an
accident it can't be it can't be and by
the way you have to use the correct term
it's not inflation that's happening
happening it's bite inflation bite
inflation that was that
who came up with that yeah yeah i think
so that was the first thing
but it is it's bite inflation it's
stagflation yeah it's people not working
and inflation at the same time which is
like the worst most dangerous thing
possible
i just i can't believe it's an accident
it's not when i saw the story from the
guardian where it was like gretchen
whitmer orders the closure of an oil
pipeline in michigan i was like
get out of here there's no way it was a
coincidence that we have a pipeline shut
down the keystone's shut down
and people are running and filling up
garbage bags with gas
and then she's like now's a good time to
shut down another pipeline yep
that's you're clearly honest you're spot
on and this is not the first time that
any of this has happened
this is the playbook to color
revolutions to bringing marxism into a
country
you need to make it as weak as possible
in so many different areas
that all you have to do is kick one leg
of that desk out
and it's all going to topple because
every single one of them has been
loosened
frogs frogs in a pot you if you so we
talked about this before
shocking the system i've been saying we
should abolish the police for the for
the past couple of months why
most of the good cops have left we've
got tremendous reports uh
michael tracy report on this huge
numbers of people arrested for not
wearing masks or running small
businesses
you had a woman in south of minneapolis
arrested because she opened her coffee
bar during coven
so you have cops arresting these people
meanwhile antifa is getting cut loose i
get it the cops still arrest them but
they get cut loose
now most of the good cops have quit and
what's left of the cops will do whatever
they're told
if you leave this system as it is we can
already see what's happening
black lives matter calls the police they
they're at a guy's house he brandishes a
shotgun in his own home they call the
cops the cops arrest him from his own
home
they don't want to abolish the police
they've weakened the police department
demoralizing to the point
where they can get cops who will come in
and enforce anything they're told
conservatives now need to be need to be
paying attention to this
because there are frogs in a pot boiling
defending the police
and that changes are slow enough to
where within a year you're going to have
your woke police force
they're going to arrest you in your own
home they're already doing it in which
case
you can be a frog in a pot or you can be
a frog someone threw a
rock at get shocked out of it you got to
think about it
i would say this this would be my
pushback to it is that i think that
the country is so divided that in the
cities that are controlled by democrats
the police forces the
police chiefs have been chosen by the
democrat mayors the police forces have
been neutered essentially and you're
right that
most of the good people have left and so
what we have
left there in those cities is police
departments that essentially bow down to
the mob
but in the rest of america we we don't
like in most parts there's some places
where we've seen them act crazy over
covet orders and stuff like that but i
can say in tennessee
like our local police they refuse to
enforce any of the mandates they refuse
to enforce anything like that
and so that's a very different world and
none of those officers are leaving their
jobs
clarify i'll clarify when the left says
abolish the police they're not talking
about tennessee they're talking about
new york city yeah
and i'm like yeah go for it i just want
to clarify that from my home state
um so you know i think that that idea
that it's all
one thing is something we have to be
very clear about but in terms of what's
happening in the big cities you know
honestly i don't know exactly what the
answer is because
let them get rid of their cops when you
look at it you know if that's what all
of them
want they're gonna have to see what the
outcomes are and honestly i think the
real answer is it's for the police who
are there right now and are putting
themselves in harm way in harm's way
when
they bow down to these people they need
to walk away from their job
ultimately my point was if we keep
sitting here as the police departments
are attacked and demoralized and good
cops quit and bad cops
take jobs we are frogs in a pot being
boiled
and you won't realize when the change
has happened when all of a sudden your
cop knocks on your door and says
you know where's your critical race
theory book prove you have it
you'll just be like how did we get to
this point because if at any point
if the democrats came out right now and
said we're going to mandate that all
police arrest anybody who exploit who
displays white privilege people would
revolt they would
people would freak out they'd be
screaming they'd be like demanding
people get fired
you do it slowly over the course of a
year two years or three years
and then people are just like did you
hear about john you got something about
white privilege i don't know what
happened and then one by one these
things keep happening and then
eventually it's normal
it's incrementalism if you do it so i'll
i'll i'll use the story of ebay which
i've told before
when ebay first started the website was
yellow did you ever hear the story no
the website was yellow
one day they decided we want to redesign
the website they made it they made the
website white
they got inundated with complaints
people were like i hate it it's awful
so they changed it back every day they
incremented it one
shade closer to white over the course of
a year a year later the website was
white and no one complained
because it was so gradual no one noticed
so
right now what's happening is you
mentioned like marxism and
coming in and weakening the country if
they came in and stood up and said
we you know i'm a marxist candidate who
wants to run for office
they'd never win no you get in the
democratic party now they've gone to the
point where they've actually entertained
socialism and it's working yep
now they can tell you socialism is a
good thing socialism is great and now
people are starting to actually they i
remember like two or three years ago
they added the word socialism to the
democratic party wikipedia page
tenets socialism they're doing it slow
enough
because you can't just do it all at once
for a few reasons
people notice right away a massive
change and don't like it but
they need to make it uh transition along
with the aging demographics
yeah so when we have these leftists on
the show and they're in their 20s
and they're like you got to vote for joe
biden and then i mention the obama
administration they go oh i was 15 when
it happened i have no idea
yeah i'm like oh so when they were
blowing up kids you weren't paying
you'll learn this time
you'll learn this time but it's not just
about the individual it's about the
demographic so you're spot on because
like fidel castro if you ask somebody is
fidel castro was he a communist you'd be
like oh yeah absolutely well he never
admitted he was
in the lead-up to the revolution he only
admitted he was a marxist
after they had consolidated enough power
he had already taken power
and they had an alliance with the soviet
union that's when he said
i'm a marxist before that he said i'm a
humanist i'm a catholic yep
yeah and then we know what happened
after that yep you look at what happens
and uh i'm sorry i i i can shout this
out whenever i get the opportunity
maduro giving a speech to a starving
nation in venezuela
and then just reaching into a drawer
pulling an empanada and taking a big old
bite you know what i'm going to do
that is that is that is them
encapsulated
can we sell that as an nft you know like
that's that's the marxism we were
talking about i believe he did that
i know it's insane they're so brazen
they know that once they've demoralized
you to that point
he can eat food in front of you as you
starve and no one will do anything about
it yep
step one is get on tv and treat
americans like dogs and tell them that
uh
you know they they can get a prize hold
on dogs are traded pretty well in this
country no
okay maybe like but i'm talking about
the training aspect the training aspect
saying cut you can have your treat
if you take your medicine that like we
saw today yeah what was that what was it
was that thing from biting i don't even
pulled up you know he's like if you get
your vaccine you otherwise you wear a
mask that's the deal and i'm like no
no it isn't joe like i don't live
wherever it is you live okay because
even though he said that
dc's operating under different rules so
the cdc comes out
and they're like if you're vaccinated
you don't got to wear a mask well
washington dc doesn't care they said
that washington dc is a federal
jurisdiction but they're doing whatever
they want
texas hasn't cared for some time yeah
they've got no mass man in florida the
same
and out here they've already announced
the end of the mass mandates in several
states and some of them are blue states
and i'm like i don't know who he's
talking to
who's joe biden talking to new york city
i guess he's talking to himself
through the guise of his abusive father
in the 50s when that's how they talk the
meaner and the more cruel you were the
more likely the kid was to be
subservient and say yes sir
i don't know man i i look at how kids
are getting raised today and it's like
i i i feel like kids today are the
example of the the epitome of
shut up mom kind of kids well the
disrespect today is crazy we got to get
that under control in america especially
dad's need to like
be a dad don't let them don't let them
talk to their mom
disrespectfully and say teach them how
to treat people because how they treat
people at home that's going to be
reflection how they treat people on the
outside and you don't need to be this
brutal dictator of a parent
to instill respect lead by example and
the first time they step out of line
take away everything that they
they like playing with and doing and
that that'll effectively work most of
the time for me
so that's a privilege i referenced the
intercept
when talking about uh donald trump and
they called him the most honest and
deceitful president
have you guys seen the intercept story
that came out about the dc riot squad
we talked about it yeah okay yep for
those that are listening at home
we are good friends with the riot squad
they are awesome
people they come on the show every so
often whenever there's like a big event
richie and you know jorge and and the
whole crew
they're here and we talk about what
happened like hey you were on the ground
tell me
tell me your thoughts and they're always
very explicitly like we're not political
we're not pro or anti-like you know we
can criticize violence and all that
stuff
richie is very very like strict about
like it's not my political opinion i'll
tell you what they did
you know like antifa did these things
that happened i was there he told us
about what happened in dc in january 6.
he was down there at the capitol filming
it and he got smeared by the new york
times they called him a writer because
he was there filming and his shirt
came off anyway the intercept writes
this uh
uh this they make this 24-minute video
claiming that the riot squad our friends
are like right-wing misinformation to
distort the facts and smear black lives
matter
so we have this from the national review
they say we shouldn't need the riot
squad but we do a response to the
intercept
they say if you were lucky enough to get
off the internet for any extended period
of time
last summer you probably would have had
no idea that cities across the country
were being consumed by political
violence on a scale unseen since the
1960s
if in may and june you limited your
media diet to the major newspapers cnn
and msnbc
you would have been unaware that intense
property damage and physical violence
was being perpetrated by rioters each
and every night in kenosha
portland and just about every other
major city and i want to point out in
kenosha there's a video
where an old man had a store was being
burned and looted and when he ran up
trying to stop people someone bashed him
over the back of the head with a rock
leaving him on the ground bleeding out
they say extremist agitators
many of whom traveled from city to city
looking for trouble assaulted bystanders
destroyed businesses and torched
buildings the only reason we know
who was responsible and how they managed
to run wild in formerly sleepy downtowns
is because of journalists like daily
callers richie mcginnis
shelby talcott jorge ventura and town
hall's julio rosas and we've had all of
them in in the studio and i will stress
they are good friends of the show
after new york times reporters and cable
news talking heads left the scenes of
daytime protests
mcginnis talcott ventura roses stayed on
the street to document the destruction
that reliably followed mcginnis got so
close to the action in kenosha
he rendered first aid to the man whom
kyle written house fatally shot
yet the intercept did they tried
smearing
richie by making it seem like he was
withholding evidence
because certainly he should have had
video footage of what happened right why
didn't he release it
he was rendering first aid to a guy who
got shot he was like being a human being
not just a human being but you whether
the person's bad or good
somebody willing to render first aid in
a critical situation like that that's
that's a
courageous person you ever see you ever
see the patriot with mel gibson
yeah and and and mel gibson's in his
house and he's got uh redcoats and
continental
you know uh army and they're all being
rendered we do this we do this because
we're good people
uh and then the bad guy he was the
british guy he's like killed them all or
whatever and it like made britain look
like extremists or whatever they got
really mad about it
but you know the point is the bad guys
are the ones
who who let you die you know like when
the joker is falling to his death batman
always saves him
batman's the good guy who doesn't want
you to die he just is trying to do right
even though sometimes it's hard
decisions
they're going to say a year later the
intercept's robert mackey seems upset
the reporting done by the daily caller
and town hall is inconvenient to his
political agenda
in a transparent attempt at the sort of
guilt by association that activists
posing as reporters just love
mackey lumps talcut and mcginnis in with
fabulous
who posted deceptively edited clips of
writing on social media to start outrage
labeling the lot of them the riot squad
i'm sorry i just got to point out they
call themselves the right what's the
right squad that actually is a cool name
yeah that's like that's a cool nickname
we had three of the crew
here on the show and i was like what
should we put and i think it was richie
right yeah he's like the dc right
okay because they're journalists who are
down there covering these things and
it's it's really it's
it's the reason i bring this up is for
one i am personally offended at the
insult to
good friends of this show like we had
richie here hanging out rollerblading
he's like in one of the vlogs like he's
literally just a friend who's hanging
out
he's a good dude he's not super
political he's like a surfer guy a
skateboarder
and simply by doing journalism they try
to destroy him that's the name of the
game
i will also mention i'm offended that we
get we get no smears in this thing they
don't mention
we want our i think i'm being somewhat
facetious but our third biggest clip
from the show
was richie mcginnis telling the story of
what happened in kenosha
explaining here's what happened here's
where i was and that's and that's it
that's because there was too much
context in the clip that's why you guys
didn't get any love they were well
right because if they showed any of that
people would have been like oh he's
straight up saying he's not political
exactly saying i have no opinion on kyle
and
what's happening it'll be fleshed out in
court and then he sat here and we
interviewed him and he said
here's what i saw here's what happened
that's it and that was a major uh uh
that's one of our biggest clips and so i
look to what they're doing i used to do
the same thing i used to go down the
ground and i
reported report all the stuff it got
dangerous of course now the intercept
glenn greenwald quit it's become a
vicious political monster
full of lies and manipulation and now
real journalists have emerged that are
threatening the narrative
defending the extremists so going back
to what you were talking about with
marxist taking over that's why i wanted
to talk about this
they can't have real journalists yeah
the irony is isn't that why the
intercept was made
isn't that why glenn greenwald did this
and found funding and did this was so
that we could have real reporting so
that people would do things without fear
and they would go after the real power
structures that try to keep people from
knowing what's going on
that's what it was for and this is the
group now who's divorced themselves
so far from what their actual mission
was
that they're now attacking people who
are doing i'm sorry you want to talk
about
an organization that divorced themselves
from the mission
there's a group it's called free press
i've known many of the people that free
press for a long time
the name of their organization free
press
they would fight censorship and defend
the first amendment and the right to
report and all that good stuff they have
a website free press.net
if they agree with and i remember when
they used to be i i
i've uh i i don't it's been a long time
but i've interviewed people there
i had several meetings with many of the
people who worked this organization
and then one day i saw one of their top
people who i had known for some time
demanding censorship that alex jones be
banned
and i said that's strange why are you
advocating
for censorship i thought you were free
press something happened to this
organization where it became woke
and their mission was no longer about
supporting free speech it was about
shutting down hate speech how did that
happen
i don't know but you look at the
intercept and you look at how glenn
greenwald
he's like hey we're doing the snowden
documents we're gonna make fearless
reporting we're gonna start this
organization and it got so bad
the dude quit glenn greenwald who
founded the intercept
quit his own company and now he's doing
independent work
and they call him you know alt-right and
far-right or whatever
which is hilarious because he's he's on
the left politically i mean very clearly
and he disagrees a lot on policy with
things that i would believe in
but he's what i would like my opposition
to be
we can actually have a conversation on
policy we can actually find
some kind of solution within our
differences say hey we actually agree on
this one part of it
let's at least implement that you can't
do that when the other group of people
behave the way that we see the current
party behaving or
i mean you whatever the intercept is i
mean this video
was look in the video the guy says
this guy robert mackey he's like the
videos they produce are distortions
and activists have taken up cameras to
combat these distortions
then he says much of the footage we got
from january 6 at the capitol was from
these
riot squad people because the right
trusted them and i'm like whoa
hold on either they're reporting both
sides
or it's a distortion but it can't be
both
and if it is a distortion what this guy
is reporting now the intercept has said
that the footage depicted from these
journalists on january 6 is unreliable
distortions not telling us the truth
okay
let's get rid of it as evidence the fbi
should be allowed to use it in fact if i
if if one of these guys like if i was
one of these people on trial whatever
i'd have my lawyer be like
your honor take a look at this reporting
from the intercept clearly these videos
are fabrication
and distortions as the intercept has
reported you can't trust these videos
sorry yep release the old ladies you've
gotten solitary yeah
seriously it shows you that
these people have no principles they
never did
but more importantly it shows the divide
between the moral frameworks of
the the disparate factions and the
culture war why you and i probably have
different politics on
several issues glenn greenwald clearly
but glenn would easily have a
conversation about all these things
we can disagree on policy but when our
moral frameworks are very similar
then we're able to have that
conversation because the goal is
actually to improve the system
when you're when your ideology is built
on just having power and oppressing
those who oppose you
then you will lie cheat and steal to
take whatever you want it also kind of
highlights a problem in corporate law
this is a little bit of a side note but
that you can
you can sell a company to a new owner
with a new ethos and they can
they can have the same name company name
but it's a different company
i mean it might have the same ip but
when someone the company is the people
that run the company for the most part i
mean that's what company is
so that disturbs me maybe we should
change it so you have to change the name
of a company if it gets sold because
disney's not disney walt disney's dead
i'll be honest i've never thought about
that that's it's an interesting thing to
think about you know i think
i'd have to think about that one in
terms of like i knew i knew a guy who
had a cyber security company
and what he told me was there was a
hassle takeover
the company was stripped and sold off
for for parts basically
but it was still a publicly traded
company so then someone else who wanted
to
start a new company just bought it and
then started doing probiotics
so it's like if you were an investor in
this company
and you were interested in cyber
security one day you woke up and they
were selling probiotics and you're like
what
is not the same company different
product different people different money
different part of the country but it is
the same company on paper
that's bizarre i've never thought about
that but you're totally right that
disney's not the same company at all as
what walt disney envisioned
not even really close and the intercept
yeah
obviously 180 from what 100 percent was
looking back
i have been noticing that glenn
greenwald now has this really unique
position where he can critique the
intercept perfectly because he knows
them
inside and out so he's been tweeting at
them he's like you guys are
doing this wrong you know this is
unethical and you've now put you know
this target on the backs of these really
serious really invested reporters who've
been they've worked hard
they have they have put themselves in so
much danger and i'm saying this is
somebody like i don't know them
i've watched their work i've seen what
they've done i have not seen one thing
from any of them
that shows that they have a personal
political persuasion to what's going on
they actually try very hard to make sure
it's not a part of the which is like
if anything you know if i saw some
people on the left doing that
i would i'd have respect for what
they're doing you know somebody like
glenn
he's at least open when he is being
political right about why
and what the reasoning is can't have the
truth man but
you know how do you manipulate people
and so it's just the the the
duplicitousness of this report from this
robert mackie guy where he's like
they're distortions
and they're also the source of all the
evidence from january 6.
yeah okay you're full of it i i think
the only clear
determination is if people like richie
are going to cover the left and the
right
and it'll be used as evidence against
people on the right he's clearly just a
journalist
he's just telling people what's going on
the problem is
they like it when he makes the right
look bad they have to forgive that
they don't like it when he makes black
lives matter look bad they have to
condemn that
the real problem is that real journalism
is a threat to their ability to attain
power consolidate power and keep it
because if you have real journalism
going on you have real reporting that's
unbiased
that is one of the most dangerous things
to them and that's why it's been all but
eliminated
if regular people knew what they were
doing it would be over
and that's the problem so they need to
do everything in their power to
obfuscate the truth
so that regular people don't know what's
going on i mean you look at kyle
rittenhouse right
so i i'm on reddit and i see a story and
it's like cal written out blah blah blah
and the top comment is the dude
literally cross state lines the gun to
hunt down protesters it's not hard or
something like that and i'm like none of
that is true
no none of it's true he worked in
kenosha it was someone else's gun he was
asked to defend a building
he rendered aid to the some of the
writers it's a complicated story
yeah but in order to push your agenda
you need
kyra has to be the villain you need the
lies yep
and who fired first it wasn't kyle
yeah it was exactly i don't remember the
guy's name but he fired it looks like
into the air he might it might
might not have been into the air so a
lot of people thought it was because
it's a grainy footage where you see the
flash and think it's going up
but i read one report that said he
actually fired directions it doesn't
really matter honestly he brandished he
fired and if you have a weapon
and you perceive that person as a threat
and then you have a mob of people
there who want to hurt you you have a
duty and a right to defend yourself
that's not hard to figure out i think
cat will get life
you do absolutely look you look at
what's going on now with chauvin and the
other other cops did you did you hear
the latest
yeah i feel differently about that than
i do the written house case i think that
on the written cow's case there's gonna
be somebody on that jury hopefully
multiple people who go
and look at this by the letter of the
law and say
this kid was defending himself maybe
because in the other case i think
they're
gonna if it's they're gonna give them
the worst in the floyd case if it's if
it's the the trial is in the kenosha
kenosha is 50 50
between democrat republican so then
you'll at least have some in the jury
being like no i'm not convicting this
kid so
hung jury at the very least however i
think most people will probably just be
cowards
and when they're in the deliberations
they're gonna someone's gonna go okay so
who doesn't want their house burned down
all right guilty all right let's get out
of here that is the biggest fear which
tells you everything about where we are
in terms of what time it is during this
color revolution we're at the point
where
mobs run justice so we have mob run
justice
what's the next step what does the
future look like for people if you don't
stand up now
and that's my argument to people is like
now is the time to do it because if
you're going to wait till people knock
on your door
that's going to be too late this is my
issue currently with police departments
we see it mostly in major cities but i
wouldn't be surprised if it comes even
in tennessee
what do you think is going to happen
when
in kenosha which is fairly republican in
many it's like 50 50.
they're burning down buildings the
police didn't stop them it was for days
they were doing this
so then regular people are going to say
i don't want my building burned down
just make it stop throw the kid in jail
whatever fun i don't care
you look at these stories where like in
milwaukee the black lives matter people
were outside this guy's home
he brandished a shotgun through the
window the cops went into his house and
arrested him while they cheered for this
it's insane and and that group of people
previously
someone in that group had set fire to
another house they were protesting at
so this guy probably was actually scared
and brandished a shotgun
maybe he shouldn't have pointed it
directly at them but he gets arrested he
was at his house though he was in his
own house
brandish all away you know somebody's
threatening your house brandish away
in tennessee we have very clear laws
about that type of thing you don't even
have to be inside the house
um to have things start to pop off so
so we're seeing this more and more where
the cops are gonna sit down and there's
gonna be
three or four cops and they're gonna see
a riot and they're gonna go what's the
riot mad about
well some guy said you know a racial
slur
well what do we do well he's allowed to
do it's the first amendment but they
won't stop rioting
if we arrest the guy will they stop they
might just arrest the guy
and the cops are going to be like sir
you're under arrest that's what happened
in milwaukee the guy was in his own home
and they were outside of his house
people who had previously burned down
another house or set fire to another
house
they didn't burn it down but they set
fire to it twice and so he's probably
scared
and he's the one who gets arrested look
at the mccloskeys they enter private
property
they're walking on private property and
they come out with guns
and they're in trouble now maybe people
are going to be like in missouri you
can't do that fine whatever
in west virginia you definitely can if
people walk under your property you can
walk up to them with your gun points and
get off my property same with tennessee
100 so it's different in different
states
i think it should be that if you enter
my property
i can pull up my weapon and say turn
around right now or i will defend my
property
in new jersey for instance where we were
before this the reason we left is that
they call it a partial castle doctrine
which basically means
it's not if someone breaks into your
home you are legally obligated to
retreat from your own home
where it doesn't matter that's called
fleeing that's not retreat you retreat
back so you're in your underwear you're
in bed your door's kicked open
and you go what do i do well you can't
use lethal force
go into the closet you have to leave
your house you have to leave your house
only if you can prove you had no
opportunity to leave your home safely
are you allowed to then use lethal force
to defend yourself which means you'll be
arrested charged and then you can
charge and then you could argue to the
judge why you were why you were in your
right to defend yourself in your honesty
in tennessee your car also counts as
part of your castle wow
nice so um somebody tries to get in your
car car jackie you can shoot him in the
face and you're good
um if that's allowed in tennessee in
west virginia you're allowed to shoot to
stop someone from
from entering your property which is
like what i always tell people like
don't
trespass out here okay in new york
people trespass and they laugh about
them like don't do that in west virginia
i don't think anyone's gonna shoot you
because people aren't insane
but they'll be legally allowed to do it
if you go onto their property
so don't do it yeah they'll probably
just walk out with a shotgun and be like
you got 10 seconds
yeah off my property yeah you mentioned
earlier that this is like a playbook
this whole
demoralization tactic basically what's
going on you build the legs so that you
can knock one out and close the system
and
and i wanted to what other situations
have you noticed this playbook
being played in terms of our society
yeah in our society all over like look
at look at how
let's start with academia okay first
thing they do
introduce the idea that kids need to see
each other is the color of their skin
instead of
their actual character okay so critical
race theory steps in then you push in
gender ideology in california as young
as first grade you're teaching them with
a gender bred man
teaching them that well you're actually
not just male or female you can be
any of these things that sound fun so
you pick
and that's something that the parent
actually has no right to opt their child
out of now in california
okay it used to be in california could
opt out when we lived there
my son at five years old had two
children in his class
come out as trans kids okay five years
old
my son wanted to be a hot dog i told
lydia that he wanted
what they're doing is they're creating
paths of division
exactly and so everything becomes
divided entirely my older daughter in
california her school they had a guy
come in and tell everybody they have
white privilege and tell the white kids
they shouldn't sit together unless they
let it have a minority at the table
because it could make minorities feel
like they're not invited
okay again teaching the kids see each
other as different by these exterior
characteristics not internal so that's
what matters
it's going back to segregation or racism
in a whole weird different regressive
way
but all of this is built to weaken
society and then same thing with just
the messaging about family
that a family no longer is is you know
this
unit that it can be anything you could
just make up whatever you want and
that's
it is whatever it is you know you can
call yourself a dad no matter what you
are you know it doesn't matter nothing
has a real definition there's no shared
language language is the next one
we can't even agree on language the
definition of what things mean
we were just talking about that before
the show that like there's all these
words
somebody could use without even knowing
they're using a word that offends
somebody because the language keeps
changing
they change the language intentionally
so that we can't communicate effectively
because shared languages
is the key to us having a cultural sort
of
peace amongst each other divide and
conquer yeah and
this goes across everything like look at
entertainment in entertainment here's
another thing
15 years 20 years of subtly giving
impressions to little kids
teenagers and adults where along the way
you teach them things and you do it
really subtly over the course of their
life so like i can give you an example
really recent history like the recent
scooby-doo movie
they give multiple impressions to ruth
bader ginsburg being a hero of women's
rights
then they go to talking about yeah in
scooby-doo which one then they talk the
most recent one
and then they talk about tinder in it
okay and then they talk about toxic
masculinity
those are the three things they hit in
that movie that are subtle points for a
kid to bring in
these impressions are in everything a
kid consumes and coming from hollywood
i'm like totally
acutely aware of all of this they do
this throughout their life and then what
happens at school
their professors their teachers who are
remarkably on the left
they reinforce those values that
entertainment is giving them
a lot of those if your family tends to
have somewhat conservative values even
if you're like a blue dog democrat
their kids then push back against those
values and think your values are
inherently wrong there's something wrong
with them because
everything i watch and everything in
school tells me that this is bad
again dividing families dividing our
culture
and the sort of i think we need to have
peace amongst each other quite a bit the
opposite of
judeo-christian values you know notably
like honor thy father and thy mother
exactly now it's your mom is dumb and
your parents are racist don't tell them
i told you otherwise they'll say racist
things
exactly trick you and parents are
putting their kids in these schools like
stop
sending your kids to these places man it
goes both ways too and entertainment too
and school stop giving money to people
who hate you
if they hate you don't give them your
money it's one of the biggest mistakes
people make
like you can't be a lazy person right
now you have to stand up for what you
believe in and if a company comes out
some will corporation they say
x is racist or this is bad and they come
out and they take social positions they
know nothing about
then divorce from them get a divorce
with your tv
divorce netflix whatever it is in your
life where this happens
or it's an and a university your kid
goes to same thing take them out pull
them out go to a different school
what are some examples like historically
where countries have gone through this
china china went through a color
revolution cuba went through it
venezuela went through this i mean
pretty much you can go through the
playbook of all these countries who
eventually turned to
you know left-wing dictatorships whether
they be socialists in the beginning or
communist
they all pretty much went through this
it was a cultural revolution that kicked
it off
and they hit all of those pillars of
culture entertainment
academia and um you know our news media
those are the places that they weaken
first because those control perception
and perception is reality for too many
people
it's not so much like a big mistake and
we talked about this earlier too
is that this idea that facts over
feelings is something that is going to
draw over
people who are not on your side already
is is actually kind of a broken idea
because
a lot of the conditioning that's been
out there has been that you're taught
that these feelings and movies and
feelings from all these different places
that you listen to as a child
are reality so you need to message an
emotional message that reaches people in
a way that says
hey emotionally this is how you put this
policy in context the left does that
really well we don't
there's one thing however that's very
different for the united states than any
of these other countries
we have a we have gun culture now it's
not just the guns because many of these
countries did have them
and then they got taken away no we have
gun culture
we have people who have tons of guns and
we'll say something like mola
was it mulan la is that you pronounce it
yeah or uh uh um
my cold dead hands so it's gonna be very
very difficult
to pull off what they pulled off and say
china where they took old people and put
them in dunce caps and then
held strung them up in the city and
started screaming and laughing at them
and mocking them until they
bent the knee and agreed to communism
because you're going to get some old
fat trucker guy who's going to be like i
don't care he's going to pull out a gun
and be like get away from me it makes me
think that it's happened
historically like throughout millennia
that the founding fathers saw that and
we're like we need to enshrine a couple
of basics
so that we can circumvent or at least
resist when this starts to happen there
were some founding fathers that didn't
want a bill of rights
and there were some that were like we
don't want the federal government have
too much power
so we need a list i think there was
originally 17 and they condensed them
got rid of some and uh now we had then
we had 10 and
the right to keep and bear arms shall
not be infringed but hey they're
cringing quite a bit aren't they
every single day they're infringing more
and more and they're messaging
why are they messaging so hard on gun
control it's because they're fully aware
that that's the one element that's a
wild card in america versus all these
other places this has happened the more
they can clamp down on that and narrow
the culture that's why a registry is
very important too
having a registry that says exactly what
people have where they have it
that's important to them because that
would be really essential if you
actually went all the way with this
but that search for control that's the
wild card is people having guns here
and it's something i tell people all the
time is like these people who have been
overtaking these other countries and who
have died or gone to gulags
they wish they had had guns when people
came to their house don't give up your
guns whatever you do whatever you think
whatever time you think it is right now
in america don't give up your guns
hitler i think established a national
registry didn't he for the guns
he did and he also he did take guns
there was confiscation
in in jewish areas so he did the same
thing castro took guns i mean this is
this is an ongoing thing you know and
of course they always talk about safety
right for safety
and for for the community to be more
just and
and more happy you know they go with all
the same stuff that they push now just
we do it in a lot prettier way in modern
times you know they they do flashy ads
and emotional pleas
that well this kills kids what's amazing
and i always ask people about this is
why have you never heard them talk about
handgun control when that's
the majority of the deaths from guns
come from handguns they don't start
there because they know
what a like that's that's not happening
they know that's not the first
step it's kind of what you said it's
incrementalism let's start with the gun
that looks scary even though
knives and stabbings kill four times as
many people as ar-15s
let's start there because it looks scary
so that's that's the incremental first
step
and and one of the challenges uh is that
the the gun control people
are really they're really dumb
and a lot of them are like lemmings you
know you play the game lemmings or they
just like walk and follow each other
because you'll hear a lot of the same
things from the same people that make no
sense
they'll be like no self-respecting
hunter whatever use an assault weapon
and then the first question is like okay
first of all what does it have to do
with second amendment
i thought that was about it it didn't
say it didn't say deer hunting being
necessary
to protect a free state the
right-to-keeping bear should not be
infringed instead
you know a well-regulated well-regulated
militia the right of the people to keep
and bear arms so i don't know where
hunting comes from
then they say assault weapon what is an
assault weapon there's no
there's never in their mind it has to
look scary looks scary means assault
weapon
yeah and you'll say like are you talking
specifically about like a carbine with
like a folding stock or something like
what is that a reference and they'll say
yeah that okay well what is it they
won't know
then they'll say but still you know no
hunter use an assault weapon and i'm
like well based on your definition or
like say new jersey's definition
you're completely correct they're gonna
use like an ar-15
chambered in like 308 or bushmaster
which by their definition is not an
assault weapon
but it's much much more powerful you
have no idea what you're talking about
these people are insane
it's because at the end of the day it
has nothing to do with actually
preventing gun crime it has to do with
the slow incremental push to take guns
out of people's hands and it's not the
criminals they want to take the hands
out of because they're not worried about
them pushing back
they like the radical government crime
is good they love that part crime is a
destabilizing factor here what have they
done and there's another question people
should ask themselves if they're curious
you know about gun control and they
haven't really decided where they they
are
is ask yourself what was the last push
democrats made to get rid of illegal
guns
in cities in places like chicago or
baltimore or memphis
when was the last time they did that and
there hasn't been this big push to get
rid of illegal guns who are on the
street
because of gangs what's an illegal gun
a gun that they stole you know a stolen
gun something something where they shave
somebody else's property so okay so the
gun isn't the issue no no the gun's not
i'm saying
why are they not going after the fact
that you know these gangs they
in many cases have stash houses where
they have tons of firearms that they've
stolen
they don't try and go get those back
well that's a property crime
exactly i think they should have those
guns i think the stolen guns
well i don't think they should have
stolen property but again so there's a
difference between the property crime
and gun ownership
yeah you know they should be allowed to
have guns legally if they get caught in
a crime then you take it away but the
fact that they're stolen
and they know where these gangs are and
they don't go in and take their guns
why do they want to take law abiding
guns this is just sort of a thought
practice you know an exercise for people
is like they want to take away my ar-15
but they don't want to take away this
guy's gun who stole it in a car jacket
well hold on i just think they're
they're they broadly want to take a take
away everyone's ar-15s
the problem is there's no way to stop a
criminal from getting a gun
oh no absolutely not no but all that
really happened no effort
the fact they make no effort to even
stop the gang crime
with guns tells you everything about why
they they go after things like ar-15
well it's it's
questionable is a gun buyback trying to
stop it
they do that um they arrest people and
charge them for having guns i don't
think they should
sometimes the only crime a person
commits if they had a gun and i'm like
how's that a crime having a guy that's
not that's but that's a lot of what they
do
so it doesn't work yeah they're still
and chicago isn't predominantly gang
crime it's like honor crime it's like
you insulted me so i'll go and shoot up
your house
that's what people do so either way i'm
like you know
that's going back to like the abolish
the police stuff i'm like shouldn't
conservatives just be on personal
responsibility at this point
if there's no cops then there's no gun
laws i do think we should let certain
areas test it out if a city wants to
have no police they vote to have no
police then go ahead and try it knock
yourselves out you're going to find out
really fast that the police kept you
safe for a very long time
i'll tell you you weaken them to this
point you're going to end up with what
the uk has they'll have little batons
and they'll do nothing but come to your
house to tell you that you insulted
somebody online
this is the big difference between the
culture war factions so
uh glenn greenwald yeah he's pretty much
left right but he's not on the left
culture or whatever to call it
i'm like center left liberal but clearly
not in that faction either
and there's one really easy way to
understand it those people are morons
why they want to abolish police and
they want to ban guns well if you get
rid of the cops who takes the guns away
you think a social worker is going to
show up to my house and be like your gun
sir i'm going to be like it's back the
way you came like have a nice day yeah
so how how do you have these people who
advocate for contrary things they're
morons they have no idea what they're
talking about
they're a chaotic destructive force of
tribalists now
to be fair to the leftists the actual
like dsa types
they're all pro-gun karl marx has a
quote
that you know uh under no under no
pretext shall the workers
you know give up arms and ammunition or
should arms and ammunition be given up
workers should frustrate this by force
if necessary so the true leftists are
lying never giving up my guns
but the problem is those people fall in
line with joe biden the democrats
because they're easily convinced by the
establishment it's the left
or at least left enough i also don't
think they want us to have guns
that's that's right right like they're
not going to go fight for us to have a
right to have a gun right
at the end of the day they want them to
have the guns the gravel institute
tweeted that what happened on january 6
was the right thing to do but by the
wrong people
so it shows you everything about what
the left actually believes yeah
or and so there's a difference between
the actual left and the culture war left
and like democrats
it's it's it's hard to quantify this i
know but the dsa people will gladly vote
for democrats
and support warmongering authoritarians
because they're like at least i'm closer
to minimum wage
like oh congratulations that's the
political party
thing bothers me that that people that
have these these ideals would align with
another person that doesn't just because
they both call themselves democrats like
who cares
about politicians there is
there is one thing i think is uh that's
very important
provides an exit from the system and
could
protect you or at least in my opinion
will protect me and it's a bitcoin
obviously
and so i really want to talk about the
story with elon musk because i think
elon musk is scamming people that's my
personal opinion elon musk is trying to
scam people uh hey look man i
i thought elon was funny on snl because
it's funny to watch him i think he's
cool for doing a lot of things i think
tesla and spacex are awesome
but i think elon should be criticized
when he does things that are bad
and i think he's trying to rip people
off so we have the story from bloomberg
musk sends bitcoin tumbling with
shock you turn on payments you may have
seen the tweet he said
uh tesla and bitcoin let me pull up his
tweet here i
i tweeted mockingham and he said
tesla has suspended vehicle purchases
using bitcoin we are concerned about
rapidly increasing use of fossil fuels
for bitcoin mining and transactions
especially coal
which has the worst emissions of any
fuel cryptocurrency is a good idea on
many levels
and we believe it is a promising future
but this cannot come at a great ex
great cost to the environment tesla will
not be selling any bitcoin
and we intend to use it for transactions
as soon as mining transitions to more
sustainable energy
we are also looking at other
cryptocurrencies that use less than one
percent of
bitcoin's energy for per transaction he
then posts this
uh so that was a couple days that was
yesterday then he posts this energy
usage trend over the past few months is
insane
and you can see bitcoin electricity
consumption has skyrocketed
dramatically the only problem harvard
business review covered this only about
eight days ago
saying that there's two reports one says
39 of energy used for bitcoin is
renewable
and another report says 73 is renewable
why
it's kind of obvious if you have a
mining operation you don't want supply
disruption you don't want to rely on
power outages
so you go to places where you have a
consistent energy supply notably
hydroelectric dams
yep where consistent electricity supply
renewable it's not so much that they're
like i don't like carbon it's like i
want a
reliable supply of energy here's what
happens
people like elon musk he comes out and
he says
tesla will now accept bitcoin the price
skyrockets
yep then they sell a bunch make a bunch
of money and say see look
yeah then they come out and say oh oh no
the environment oh geez
oh they're using coal for electricity oh
no we got to stop
then the price tanks back down and all
the rich people
who don't need their assets liquefied
say i don't care think about this way if
you're somebody who makes 500 bucks a
week
and you see what's happening with the us
dollar and buying power and you see
what's happening
with bitcoin you're like i'm gonna buy
some bitcoin so you do
then elon musk makes this announcement
and the price drops it's like 12
or something and you're like i'm gonna
lose 60 bucks so you panic sell
and you still end up losing 60 bucks
because you need
liquid cash in your life you're not rich
you only got a few hundred dollars
millionaires billionaires well they can
pay their rent in their mortgages and
their car bills
and still keep millions of dollars in
crypto even when the price drops they're
going to shrug and go
i don't care and they'll buy the dip yep
that's right they'll buy the dip a
hundred percent
they'll buy it back up this is how they
keep people
poor because people see elon musk and
they panic and they sell
now some people a lot of people are
getting wise to the game i remember back
when bitcoin hit 20k people were like
mortgaging their homes
then you get news about like countries
banning bitcoin or whatever and they
panic
and they sell and they lose tons of
money and if you did
buy bitcoin and held it and it went up
to even now at 47.48 even though it's
dropped from 60
you're still double your money it's
probably going to go up
so that's why all of the smart people
are the rich people they buy the dip
but don't be surprised when you see
governments billionaires banks make an
announcement about how they're getting
rid of bitcoin
then poor people who aren't smart enough
panic and sell it and they laugh as they
buy it all back up
that's the cycle they need a way to
control the market because they control
the stock market they need the same
control over crypto and they found it
you know and i think that you're you're
right you identified something important
like elon has been great on a lot of
things
but i'm glad i have alerts set um and i
got i got and saw that one immediately
and i was like oh this is bad this is
the worst thing he's done
in recent times in terms of his public
persona this could shift a lot of the
way people think about him
because it was very clearly he knew what
was going to happen he had to know and
if he doesn't then he should
probably shut his twitter down for a
couple days and think about it now get
this now he's saying that he's going to
be
he's working with with doge devs to fix
doge
think about what he's doing he's pumping
doge he's pumping doge
he called himself the dog they called
him the doge father and snl even though
the price went down
apparently his son is mining dosh it's
really really obvious dough is just
trading right now for 40 cents
meaning you can easily buy thousands
upon thousands of doge
then you get doge up to 100 bucks or
whatever you make tons of huge return
huge
huge return way more than bitcoin at
this point so there was there was a
period where
bitcoin was drop was jumping
ridiculously fast
so from november till now bitcoin's gone
up substantially like hundreds of
percent
but there was a period where it's like
it was at a dollar and it could jump to
50
that's a 50 x return yeah now that
bitcoin's trading much much higher
it's it's it's harder for those swings
it's starting to stabilize right
so what happens is people start buying
alt coins
that are trading for like a fraction of
a penny
so if it's trading for the smallest
decimal point it can only double
you'll double your money so now elon's
probably in
in my opinion looking at bitcoin going
bitcoin's great
but is there a coin we can get and pump
it up really really fast
dogecoin's trading at five cents tons of
people will buy it
we can make a movement we can put out a
tweet everybody buys it
so apparently one dude became a
millionaire and like was posting about
it
yeah he had he had he had the right
amount of doge and then
it broke a certain amount and he made a
million bucks so
one of the big guys at goldman sachs
left because he made millions yeah yep
so it seems to me like
this announcement is more so he can pump
doge
but doge is inflationary there's no cap
it they produce what is it like what are
they doing 14 million per day or
something
yeah i don't know somebody i'm pretty
sure they can just keep going with it
right they can just keep going just keep
going yeah and so people are going to go
in they're going to cash out quick
and i think doge is funny i still have
thousands of doge
and i'll hold on to it because who knows
if elon musk is doing with this i'll
hold on to what i guess
but i still think i think bitcoin's
gonna reach a million bucks i gotta say
doge is trash it is absolute useless
trash
as a token it may change in the future
it's not a token
or as a coin yeah whatever it's it's
gunk it has no value
functionally i disagree it only has like
monetary value it doesn't do anything
basically just
monetary is a lot of value no it's it's
an inflationary cash
yeah it doesn't it doesn't have any
technical value it's better i i i i
maybe it will in the future maybe better
than us well the us dollar has
zero technical value as well yes so i'd
rather have i'd rather have dojo than us
dollars
too right that's why i'm like i'm gonna
keep saying i don't want the dollars
within the closed system of crypto let's
get it out ahead of this doge's junk
i don't know why elon's trolling people
like this no i disagree with it's
because of returns
it's like i mean yeah he's making and
it's the memeable it's so memeable yes
you know with the dog that's that's
the easiest to know and he's making
people rich which is like up
kind of inverting the monetary scheme of
this consolidation of wealth to the top
he's like giving the
eh i mean that's debatable he's honestly
making way more rich people rich than
poor people rich honestly if i'm being
real like somebody like me
like during the dip yesterday i could
buy a bunch and make way more back on my
return
in terms of spending power than somebody
who makes 500 a week or something you
know
we talked about this like last week that
there are programs that automatically
buy and sell
yeah so imagine this uh elon announces
the bitcoin thing and the price dropped
like 47.
it dropped so low it probably triggered
a bunch of people to auto buy
it jumped back up to like 51. then what
started going down
it triggered an auto sell so people
right then were making three grand per
coin automatically without even doing
anything without thinking because the
price fluctuations in the volatility
so when someone like elon knows he can
tweet and cause prices go crazy
you know for a fact that elon musk knew
when he tweeted this
it would drive the price down and all of
his friends did
and how many people that knew elon was
going to do this
sold their coins because how do you
track it sold at 58k
and then said okay elon you're good to
go elon post it drops a for it and they
buy back in
yep and then elon sends a text i think
i'm going to pump doge today but he
doesn't say pump but you know what i
mean he's like on the phone and he's
like i'm going to let people know i'm
going to do this with
and then they go and they buy that so
and then that rides
i i think bitcoin i have a decent amount
of bitcoin i have a decent amount of
ethereum
and i have doge and i have cardano and
those are the things that i'm looking at
i think doge is inflationary i think
doge
is going to have value based on
confidence of the meme ability
elon might pump it up but i wouldn't at
like i wouldn't advocate for the
function of doge it's just funny
yeah it's 100 but uh uh bitcoin
ethereum and cardano are the ones i do
have that i do have confidence in
and i you know i think a lot of these
tokens are bunk
you got to be careful about tokens i
don't know if cardano is actually a
token or
if it's an actual crypto i think it's
its own crypto functions it's a proof of
state crypto like ethereum
but uh a lot of these tokens like shiba
i think sheba is a token right i don't
know i just saw it recently
um so tokens you can just click a button
boop you have tokens yeah i think it is
see i i don't know enough about tokens
tokens i'm gonna have to educate myself
on more so with like
uh with a cryptocurrency it's truly
decentralized like bitcoin yeah
you have you can create the code and
then start the program and then do the
proof of stake or proof of work to get
it
uh they can be centralized still even if
they're coins but bitcoins truly
decentralized
cardano is a utility token because it
helps to facilitate smart contracts
this is very convoluted to me yeah yeah
but but is is it its own independent
blockchain like ethereum or is it
it's on it's not on the ethereum network
so then i don't i don't think it's
actually a token
a token typically refers to someone goes
on a computer and presses enter and then
a bunch of tokens appear okay whereas
interesting the the coins
are like doge and bitcoin where you
do some work proof of work or proof of
stake to generate them
but i don't know maybe it's just
semantics yeah i got that info from
nasdaq.com
is that it was a token maybe i'm wrong
in my terminology there yeah
more crypto experts but i will say this
a lot of people are uh first and
foremost
probably the the main reason i'm saying
these these three tokens is because like
when you pull up coinbase or whatever
they're like the top listed or something
yeah
and so i'm looking at establishment
support and
i'm not gonna pull up some no-name token
or crypto and be like oh that's the one
yeah i think a lot of people do that
because they'll buy a bunch at a cheap
price and then try claiming this is the
one
i just went on coinbase and i was like
here's the top performing here's the top
you know
like that people are looking at and i
was like all right i read about them and
i and i bought the clear
you know i got a quick uh explanation
from bitdegree.org which i've never
heard of before
is this bitcoin college yeah let's do
this uh the difference between a coin
and a token coins are native to their
own blockchain while tokens have been
built on top of another blockchain oh
right
so i i don't think cardano is built on
another blockchain it's interesting but
i just saw it was a token who knows
maybe let's find let's get the
developers of cardano if you guys are
listening
yeah then maybe maybe i don't i don't
want it but i but i have uh
a decent amount i don't i went out like
years and years ago i bought a bunch of
ridiculous things
i think i have someone i think i think i
do have an account with like um
do you know what bsv is or whatever i
have bitcoin cash only because bitcoin
forked and then you get bitcoin cash or
whatever
wasn't bsv like an overseas thing to buy
cryptos no uh it was it's it's a fork of
bitcoin
so basically there have been several
civil wars in bitcoin where
people are like this is not the true
vision of satoshi in the white paper so
i'm taking the existing network and
forking it off
and it clones the network but creates a
separate coin
so if it happens and you're holding
bitcoin
the split you'll have equal amounts
bitcoin cash and bitcoin
and then people just made money
overnight yeah so this is the craziest
thing when when
when bitcoin and bitcoin cash forked all
of a sudden people's money doubled
like because now they had twice as many
coins yeah and then there was a weird
fluctuation between the two of people
trying to figure out which one was going
to win and then bitcoin clearly took
over because bitcoin is bitcoin and
everything else is just claiming to be
something good or better
so anyway long story short regarding
this elon thing
i want to play a little juan williams
here i think maybe he really truly
believes that
it is destroying the environment there's
too much coal being burned and he wants
to
pressure the industry to move towards
renewables and he's
he's using this as a heavy hand i i
think i'm gonna i'm gonna
i think that's more of the mentality
than let's let's get but have you seen
his mining operations
like four tesla batteries i mean these
are not friendly at all to the
environment and i have a tesla i'm
saying this you know like
i'm fully honest about this but it's not
exactly environmentally friendly
how the batteries are made but on top of
that it was a few years ago
elon replied to somebody about the
output and the energy that it takes to
uh
mine a bitcoin and he actually agreed
with them that it was
energy efficient that's the that's the
term they use so it's interesting that
he changed his mind now
when you know the mining practices have
only trended towards
more energy efficient since then not
less efficient it seems like people have
been in his ear
yeah that's what it feels like it feels
like somebody's actually pushing
this but i think he also has to be smart
enough with his platform his reach
his ability to shake the crypto market
you know
he's got to know that if you jump onto
something like this you're gonna hurt a
lot of normal people
and that's the one warning i do have
about like doge to people is like yes
you can get really high returns
but if you're the type of person who's
not invested very much in your life
i would advise not getting involved
because it's very volatile and
you can get really scared when you have
a dip where it feels like oh my god i'm
losing 25
of my savings or you can go to the
casino yeah if you want to play the game
so
uh bla bitcoin is a decentralized coin
so there's no one who has strong control
over it there's there's questions about
51
attacks and um quantum computing how
could be disruptive
ethereum is they're building software on
top of it cardano's basically the same
thing
i was just looking it up it's like the
co-founder created his own version of it
and the reason why i think ethereum is
so great is that they build programs on
top of it yeah
cardano is basically the same thing so
i'm looking at that and i'm like
all right you know i think these things
have a function more so than bitcoin but
bitcoin is still great
i'm not i'm not super interested in a
lot of these tokens where they're like
trying to claim it'll do something you
know other than
can you build programs on top of it so
there's a lot of tokens that exist
within the ethereum network and i'm
always like yeah but ethereum is the is
the main driver of all that so
don't take advice from me you do you
these are the things i'm looking at and
i'm [ __ ] so
don't listen to me because can i ask you
if i was real quick if i was a smart guy
about bitcoin in 2011 when i kept
talking about every opportunity i had to
buy it i didn't
what do you think will happen when a
major government
like let's say our own or maybe germany
introduces their own digital
what's happening yeah it is central bank
but i mean win when it's out when it's
out and people can buy it
and it can be traded and it's on all the
different things
what do you think will happen to
everything else they'll go up in value
you think
everything will go up in value yeah so
uh
bitcoin if bitcoin goes up everything
goes up if bitcoin goes down everything
goes down so this is from cnbc wall
street banks brace for digital
digital dollars is the next big
disruptive force they're talking about
a central bank digital currency i mean
dollars are already digital
there's just no blockchain for it it's
the banking ledgers that track
everything
so yeah but it's really for it's about
feeling like
they are their own crypto you know which
is actually why i would disagree in
terms of them
riding up or down together i think that
when a government a major government
releases one of these
they're actually going to have an
inverse correlation where
when one is performing well the other
will perform not as well
and you know vice versa i think that
it's going to feel a little bit
more like their counterweights to each
other in a weird way
and i think it's they're hoping that
that's how it'll work
kind of like tether you follow tether at
all i i
i'm trying to understand what the um how
it would tie in
i knew a little bit about it like tether
is always worth
one u.s dollar and finance they're both
one dollar
yeah there's actually a lot of them now
um i think gusd is one of them and uh
there's there's several now
those would correlate really well then
yeah and i would think that a central
bank token would be like that
it would always be worth it would be
static value and then all the other
cryptos would fluctuate around that you
could always get
uh uh dollars worth of that token
possibly or they would all ride with
almost like how the dollar works now
except for their hope would be
you know maybe there's a way to be able
to make that
more monetarily functional and also
beyond that
trackable you know like that's the real
goal they want to be able to see what
people are doing
yes um and i just i don't think they're
going to connect together in terms
of going up in value together or down in
value together i think that they're
going to end up having
a correlation where one goes up one goes
down
we'll see as it is that's in the future
though that's coming if bitcoin goes up
tether although it says it stays at one
dollar
has gone down because bitcoin has gone
up they're relative to each other
yeah so well how about we take some
super chats that went fast
and if you haven't already smash the
like button subscribe to this channel
share the link to this channel with your
friends to uh or with the video to help
help the show grow and uh don't forget
to go to timcast.com become a member
because we'll have an exclusive members
only segment coming up
later in the night all right where are
we at
next pack says you can see rod rawfudge
in gaza on snapchat map
interesting
roddy the rotsky says hey tim you've
called people stupid for getting
multiple canisters of gas not tupperware
and different machines may need gas
mixed with oil which will not work for
other tools
so i've called people stupid when they
have like stacks and stacks of gas cans
but i have said there were there was a
story of a woman who was filling up a
gas can and they screamed at her that
she was hoarding gas when it was like
she's like it's my lawnmower
so i've i've had you know like small
mopeds where you got to mix the oil in
the gas and all that i totally get it
yeah i was actually thinking that when i
saw a picture on twitter the other day
of somebody trashing somebody for
getting one can of gas i was like i do
that all the time for my daughter's atv
i go and i grab the gas and i stick it
in the back of the car and it smells
terrible and i drive it home
tex marine says tim have you had enrique
tario on your show
yes we have we have indeed i like that
guy
well he's a very bad person according to
the media so you gotta you like bad
people ian apparently
i'm dirty all right we got uh let's try
and find some uh
acme products says if gaza is an
open-air prison then why don't the
egyptians let them out
that's a very good question that is a
very good question yeah why doesn't
egypt open my guess is because
israel doesn't want them to but i don't
know oh israel would be fine with that
yeah they don't want to leave that's
really what it comes down to they
believe it's their home and
they're angry but ultimately you know if
you truly believed
that this was a prison and that you know
that death was essentially
like just around the next corner and
that you know your kids are in danger
and all those things like i
me i don't care what my home is my kid's
safety is number one
i'd be out of there i'd be heading over
to egypt and i'd be like i'm an egyptian
now
yeah you know that's just it defies sort
of just common sense that we don't see a
wave of people going you know what we're
done with this we're done with this
behavior we're done with there being a
fight all the time we're done with this
constant struggle
we're done with the palestinian
authority paying for
terrorists who kill israelis they pay
them you know they
pay somebody if they go and kill an
israeli soldier they pay them for life
okay that's not a terror group that's
the palestinian authority pays those
okay that says everything so if that's
the culture there should be a huge wave
of people saying you know what i've had
enough i'm taking my family we're going
somewhere else
and there's not all right best auntie
ever says
washington govern uh government or
governor gov announced full opening 6
30.
the day de blasio said they'd open 7-1
i said inslee would open earlier so he
could say look what i did for you
to beat other blue states inslee said
the vaccine is a ticket to freedom
sick not surprised wow
gerald johnson says 1.2 million gallons
of gas leaked from colonial pipeline and
a week later it's cyber attack
really do you wanna you wanna look that
up yeah let me do that
that is interesting jeremy mcdougall
says if darkseid wanted to hack into a
better future
they should hack isps and social media
sites for people force people off the
internet and get them to see what
they're actually doing in the real world
yeah but i think darkseid's like we want
money so we can spend it on things we
like
not change society so that we can't
spend the money on things we like
christopher maher says so you're saying
they pushed trump out of office for the
exact reason he got in the first place
seems about correct the establishment
did not like anything trump was doing
until he fired missiles at syria then
they were like all right that's pretty
good that was why i mean every
everybody on tv this is the day that he
became the president of the united
states of america
yep now now how many children were
killed in this strike
the the more the more casualty there is
the more likely it was that there would
be a protractor
a big big old war out there the more
serious they look into the camera and
say
he's done a great job today well there's
a guy on cnn i'm this is not real
i'm making a joke so you know this and
they're like donald trump fired missiles
into syria
and the guy goes still i mean he's
trying to be presidential
and this is not enough well just a
minute there sir we have breaking news
17 children were killed well now
actually i think donald trump is
is much more presidential now how many
children do you know what though it is
true
it is presidential if you count obama as
presidential then going and bombing
children in the middle east is
presidential according to obama's
standards so there you go
hey if trump wants one to be nearly as
good as obama i guess they need to blow
up more kids
yeah well he didn't want to do that so
yeah uh it looks like uh colonial
pipeline did leak
1.2 million gallons of gas in
huntersville
wow i'm not sure where hundreds of
villages that's a lot wow
what is do you know what like a normal
pipeline spill is
how many gallons it is that's the only
thing i'm not sure about is like you
know is that like 100 million gallons
like a big one or it sounds like a lot
but it's one of those weird things where
like is it really actually
i guess it was 17 times what they
originally estimated that's not good yes
and then all of a sudden there's a cyber
attack yeah that's a little odd
orion says tim pay attention to glenn
greenwald in the u.s he might be
professional but since he moved here to
brazil
he has been doing journalism as biased
as possible to the left
keep up the great work yeah he's uh he's
very anti
um who's the guy in brazil yeah yeah
i mean that i kind of i kind of don't
pay attention to because it's not my
country
you know this goes back to my ideology
of like part of running for office i'm
anti-war i want to stay out of their
business brazilians elected bolsonaro
he's not going and pillaging the entire
country
it's none of our business this is a
great jesus quote i mean it's not really
a quote but they said he said this
take the plank of wood out of your own
eye before you try to take the mode of
dust out of your friend's eye
yeah it'd be great if we did that here
in america
freedom thoughts says tim the great and
free state of missouri
has full castle doctrine we're making
steps to oust the federal government's
gun laws and all counties
have met and talked about arresting
federal authorities if they break the
second amendment
i think happened in ohio some they
arrested some atf guys who are trying to
like serve
papers or something we should have
sanctuary states for the second
amendment absolutely
i want tennessee to be absolutely one we
just passed concealed carry
um what you know constitutional carry
where anybody here in tennessee we just
pass it
it'll become active on july 1st um
and i think that that's that's a win but
a bigger win would be saying you know
what
feds can't come in they can't touch your
guns and we need to codify that in every
state
you see we talk about colorado
revolutions and all that stuff but based
on the fact that we all got guns it
sounds more like a civil war as a bruin
i'm not i'm not disagreeing with you in
terms of where this can end up
and if you'd asked me a few years ago i
probably wouldn't
have been like oh yeah that's definitely
but i see it now where it could end up
there because we are different
and you can't put the genie back in the
bottle on the gun we have it's over 300
million guns in america
yeah it's yeah i think it's 400. it's
probably close to 400 yeah you know and
that doesn't go back in the bottle it's
it's not going away me too i'm a big boy
i'm actually i'm a huge i mean not
surprisingly people who fled cuba's
family members even second third
generation they're very pro-gun yeah you
know
um i got big news though what is it
on saturday i'm going to pick up the sig
m400 that crowder got for me
a year ago as a present so
so i was like i was getting my first gun
and i'm like and so i was on crowder's
show and he's like i got big news for
you buddy
we're getting you sent a sig m400 to be
incent and and i was like wow awesome
and i got sent to a shop that was too
far away because of new jersey's gun
laws and the modifications had to be
done to it
and so i was never able to get it uh
they find they called me up and they're
like we found this thing and i was like
whoa
cool send it send it on over to my ffl
and they were like you got it
i'm going to go pick it up we're going
to film it that's finally going to get
the gun that crowder sent me
that's awesome it's going to be great
and your name engraved on it
yeah you should that'd be awesome no
we'll we'll see
it'll be fun we'll film picking it up
and everything and then we're gonna go
saturday
okay and then we're gonna go on sunday
to the range and film a bunch of stuff
yeah man i think west virginia just
passed constitutional carry
that's awesome i don't maybe they no no
i'm sorry i'm sorry they've had it
already they've had it for a while some
other state that just did it yeah utah
or something
yeah jesse kent says you absolutely have
a right to defend your life with deadly
force in missouri missouri kansas and
oklahoma have less state firearms
restrictions than texas yeah texas you
had to actually go
like go to a class and like you know
prove you could shoot
but now they're getting rid of that now
it's just you used to be like that in
tennessee too you'd have to go to a
class you have to get a go to the dmv
and all that
now starting july 1st it'll just be
carry it you own it
legally carry it around very cool and
you can do it's open or or concealed
wow bjc says missouri law says you can't
threaten lethal for
lethal force unless you have a reason to
use it if you keep your gun pointed down
no issue mccloskey's pointed at crowd
but weren't in imminent danger
imminent danger is an opinion yeah
that's an opinion 100 i think they were
an imminent danger i agree yeah i think
had they not had guns
um their house could have been robbed
they could have been beaten they
probably
went kills because they were they were
sitting on their patio so there are
clearly they were already outside they
were outside eating when the crowd came
and so you you see what happens when
the crowd if you're a car on the street
minding your own business they start
banging on the windows
in portland they smash the windows of
some cars so
you're not gonna be able to convince me
that there's no reasonable fear of
imminent danger
i don't know if they were in imminent
danger but i think they have a right
as these people just minding their own
business to see a huge crowd and be
alive they're
they're entering private property i
think there's imminent danger
if i was on a jury i'd give them an
award
definitely a not guilty verdict but
there'd be an award too
has the jury reached a verdict we have
your honor but we have a question the
verdict we have is neither
uh guilty nor not guilty it's actually
we'd like to pin a medal yeah we'd like
to give them a golden award and the
government should give them 10 thousand
each
can we do that and the judge is gonna be
like uh let's
check this and then there's like a
golden retriever comes in and the golden
retriever is like you know the the
bailiff and then the
shipments ensues and then they're like
it turns out there's no rule stopping
the jury from a warring yes
and then an old lady walks in i thought
we agreed on a hundred thousand
yeah and then it's called like court bud
oh yeah
all right rasgarh says love the show tim
on the topic of gun culture
you should try and get carl casarta from
in-range tv on
he's a different kind of personality
when it comes to gun culture and his
background is an infosec please check
him out interesting
uh daniel lawrence says robbie is kind
of off handguns are already the most
regulated in new york state
oh i didn't say that they they're not
passing things i'm saying they're not
pushing that in they're targeting
they're not targeting it publicly
they're not talking about it because
they know that that's not popular
sweet lou says tim according to uscca
app nj is a castle doctrine state with
no due to retreat while in your dwelling
except i've talked to lawyers and i
looked it up on numerous websites
and i talk to the cops and they all say
it's partial castle doctrine
you need to in order to qualify for
staying in your home you have to pass
like three different criteria
and if it is possible for you to safely
leave your home you must do so
they call it castle doctrine but heaven
forbid
you actually defend yourself then it's
just an affirmative defense but i was
defending myself in my own home could
you have left prove to us you you you
could you couldn't have
rad number two says i have had a bet
with gun grabbers a hundred thousand
dollars in cash to them if they can
legally buy an actual assault rifle
without a background check
this bet has been standing for over 10
years and still no one has taken me up
on it
it's actually it's actually a good bet i
think you know what i'll do
100 000 is too much obviously if you
said a hundred bucks
i'll bet you a hundred bucks you can't
buy an assault rifle without a
background check
you'll make a hundred bucks because they
can't do it i'll tell you this
i bet you even with a background i i
want you on a bet
that you can't go into a gun store and
buy an assault rifle
without a background check no no with a
background check i'm just saying right
now
would you would you how much money would
you bet i'll bet you right now
that you can't walk into a gun shop and
buy an assault rifle
are you mean ar-15 i said assault rifle
okay
there you go that's that i like that
select fire rifles they don't sell to
civilians
yeah there you go well but i i count on
you you can't pay the nfa
well 200 it'll take you like a year so
you're not gonna be able to
take that so technically someone might
be like okay because you can walk in and
pay for it you just can't take it
yeah so i'll be like the better thing is
i bet you won't be able to buy an
assault rifle from a gun shop
and actually be like it's hard to phrase
you got to phrase it right
i bet you you won't be able to acquire
get a and
get i bet you can't get an assault rifle
at a gun shop right now i bet you
let's go do it how much you want to bet
100 bucks let's go and you'll show up
and the first thing will happen is the
bag we don't have any
okay who has one then you'll show up and
they'll be like okay this is great
so if you want to buy it then you got to
just do the nfa paperwork it can take
then you've got to get fingerprinted so
you can't just go and get one
they're going to spend way more than
their hundred dollars yeah right and
then afterwards i'll be like oh
congratulations you got an assault rifle
it took you a year
yeah crystal kim says elon
made my crypto cry today he needs to
just stop
he is a rich person trying to take your
money so don't don't panic sell well
i'm not giving advice do whatever you
want it's okay to cry sometimes you'll
be better tomorrow and so will the
crypto
all right nolan bus says elon's tweet
was perfectly timed to dip kryptos into
a very bullish pattern
this will be the dip before the massive
rip elon knows energy consumption on
bitcoin is security feature and value
elon showing the massive influx in
energy consumption
means we're we're in my opinion we're on
the verge of a massive
burst in price because it means more and
more people are jumping into mining
crypto so when the price of bitcoin
skyrocketed
a bunch of people probably said there's
a huge upside to mining
the energy consumption skyrocketed which
means bitcoin is probably going to go up
in value because more and more
organizations are starting to adopt it
yeah we're starting to use it
ascendiate media says why are you lying
tim bitcoin dipped before the tweet
bitcoin was was was like what would it
get to like 61 or something
and it went down a little bit yeah 55.
and then it dropped from 57 to like 55.
i mean this was immediate it was like
yeah and they watch it they all dropped
after that tweet 100
all of them did every single one i
literally i went i saw the tweet
i read a couple comments i went and i
looked at the price of crypto
and they were all just falling down like
a falling knife
as fast as they could put it into tether
and they wait and then they buy it
says cardano is on its own blockchain
it's blockchain is uroboros
finance is is binance smart chain
ethereum is ethereum blockchain etc
interesting so i get the idea is that
the ethereum is the token of the
ethereum blockchain
bitcoin is the token of the bitcoin
blockchain i guess yeah
there you go sean anderson says what
happens if the natural gas grid gets
hacked in winter in the north
who uh would have thought pipeline would
be independent plc not networked
rachel maddow said that what if russia
hacks the
the the electricity and turns off the
power in the winter
in fargo well this is the inherent
problem though with um nobody doing
anything in the bible administration
being like we'll do a private company
we'll see what happens
yeah like because they've now given five
million dollars to hackers hackers are
now incentivized going 5 million bucks
that's pretty cool that's a good point
and so
they're going to go now and what other
things are exploitable where we would
pay in a heartbeat to get them back on
energy our power grid water i mean
these things are common sense we need
these things you can really start
a real crisis in america if you go and
do this and it's a quick way for those
hackers to make cash and we just told
them we negotiate with terrorists we
just do it through private companies now
it's crazy how vulnerable the power
lines are yeah 100
yep all right crypto curious says tim
you should contact charles hoskinson he
co-founded ethereum and is the creator
of cardano
yeah cardano is its own blockchain and
not an erc token that would actually be
really great
somebody actually tweeted at me and at
him and they're like oh they were just
talking about you we should have you on
irl
that'd be fantastic so we get someone to
actually come in and explain how they
built it what it does and
go in depth when you invited me on the
show i was like
you were like when are you gonna come on
on tim's show i was like whenever he
asked me because this was like this was
like
the probably 80th person that was like
when are you gonna go to tim shows like
whenever he asks me and then you were
like yeah i'm i'm asking you
i think that i had messaged you and i
think that it got you know lost in the
shuffle i know if you have open dms
it gets lost yeah it's it's ridiculous i
was like we did ask you robbie come on
yeah no you did and you were great about
it um i would have been like
what is wrong with this guy like delete
you're not coming on
but you're so sweet about it all right
archie rhea
ray says tim proud floridian here
desantis said
and proved he will pardon any floridian
for covett violations
get charles hoskinson on the show he is
the founder of ada cardano
and has amazing ideas for blockchain
also please tell carl cardano
please tell carl cardano better than
ethereum well i don't know what's better
or worse all i know is that they're very
similar and i think ethereum is amazing
technology
and if you've got a co-founder and he's
doing something similar
i think they're both just amazing
technology you look at minds for
instance and this is why i'm looking at
it
minds.com amazing social network bill's
doing great things with it
and it uses tokens in a very brilliant
way so that you can basically run the ad
system it's a decentralized way of doing
ads
mine's not necessarily it's it's
semi-decentralized but
you earn tokens by just producing
content and you earn tokens because
people are using tokens to buy ads
so it's an interesting way that's
interesting i just spent five tokens to
boost the post for five thousand views
today it felt so good
right right so it's it's it's a really
fascinating system and i think it's
interesting
and it's built on ethereum ethereum
allows software to be built on it
and so i'm looking at like the top
cryptos and i saw
cardano was similar same guy and i'm
like
these are the three that i think are
good these are the ones i bought i'm not
giving anyone advice
you do what you want to do people
probably are bringing up a bunch of
other
coins and tokens so don't take any
advice from me i'm just full disclosure
this is the ones that i have
i've heard the best things about
ethereum i'd love to meet you know the
guys who came up with it because
it's interesting something that i think
that i haven't seen anybody in politics
really
ask directly to people who are like
super involved in the building
of these you know futures of currency in
many ways
is hey what are you guys worried about
government doing to interfere in this
process because
i want to understand the intricacies of
what they see down the line 10 years
from now what is the problem going to be
with government
getting in the way of this prospering
yeah you know that's something that i
think more people need to understand
i think for truly decentralized coins
the government can never do anything
it's an honor system yeah so with like
um what is
zcash anonymous you know i don't know
but i think bitrex stopped serving it so
it may be they did
yeah i mean they stopped serving monero
yeah because of us regulations probably
monero so bitcoin every transaction you
can see yeah i think monero and zcash i
could be wrong
you can't so ransomware hackers will be
like
you want stuff yup the the obfuscated
hard to track
and money laundering there's a bunch of
tricks for laundering bitcoin as well to
make it hard to know
who did what yeah danny douglas says
navy nuke here ama you should have
colleen noir on he's an attorney and
expert in 2a
also he's a really great guy does a good
job explaining why we need second
amendment
he has a standing invitation i am
familiar with him he's great
eric miller says it's still a good idea
to get your carry permit for reciprocity
with other states otherwise it's only
good for your state
also tennessee also has 10 gigabit
internet and a nuclear-powered dam in
chattanooga
all right we're moving to nashville
that's it because honestly i'm telling
you
if you had me as the rep there you have
all this greatness going on you got open
carry concealed carry
just constitutional carry it's going to
be a great place i want tennessee to be
known as the free estate in this country
like real freedom you know pretend right
it's hard
amazing weather's pretty good yeah i
love the weather i went there only when
i was young and we stayed on a lake it
was incredible
yeah you get you get like any southern
state you get a little humid period for
like
you know like six eight weeks something
like that
fall is gorgeous during winter i love
winter clothes i'm a big
like i love coats i love all that stuff
i like dressing warm i like warm socks
so i'm a big fan
well yeah there's some mountains in in
tennessee you know obviously there's the
um you know uh what's it called um next
to dollywood there's
i'm trying to think this other place
that you guys would like um
god what's the name of it they have like
this restaurant a media studio and all
this stuff
i'll send it to you but there's a bunch
of places you guys would like to visit
that are really cool but we've got
beautiful mountains right
here y'all are competing with texas and
florida tennessee needs to pass one of
these social media protection bills
yep we're working on it we're working on
it absolutely cool yeah
still working on it with uh with texas
being the best
i mean it might not guarantee your
protection because they'll go to a
federal lawsuit and they could over
always over
overturn your you know say no but if the
state gives you those protections you
could win at a local court and then
force the company to take you uh
somewhere else imagine what's gonna
happen when you have
hundreds of thousands of people okay
maybe tens of thousands of conservatives
with small accounts who are banned for
saying learn to code yeah
they file immediately with the court in
texas and then all of a sudden
facebook has to answer 100 you know 100
to
you know 50 000 individual lawsuits yep
all of a sudden they're going to be like
we can't afford to do that yep and
their initial reaction is going to be
text we're not going to operate in texas
but
you get every red state to do the same
thing
that's how you change their behavior and
that's why i've said
every governor of every state needs to
grow some courage
get out there and do the same thing
there's all these governors who are not
very well liked right now because of
covet policy
and my advice to all of them is the same
look at what desantis is doing
copy it and people are going to like you
yeah because he's listening to people
he's essentially he's he's more of a
populist than in old school you know
like
that's something we don't talk enough
about we are not the mitt romney
corporate raider era republican party
we're a populist movement we care about
people we care about workers
we care about things like you know
having no more endless wars
this is the future for us and the way
that we do this is
let's clone ron desantis put him over
all these states clone them
how about without the senate
or the house yeah you know fat little
the president's gonna pull off right but
we need more people
to rise up with the ideology that are
willing to do what's necessary
and you know i do recognize something
really interesting
the media attacks that work on all the
weak republicans in dc don't work on
desantis
and a lot of people in dc they love
doing workshopping and wasting money on
getting
consultants they should really consult
those consultants to study
why the media attacks don't work on him
it's not hard to figure out
yeah all right waffle sensei says they
are trying to destroy the credibility of
riot squad
because richie is going to be a if not
the
key witness in the rittenhouse case the
narrative must be set long ahead of the
trial richie must start anti-tweeting
now
no he should just keep doing what he's
doing but it's true he's going to be one
of the most important witnesses that is
going to lay the groundwork for
in my opinion a self-defense argument
for uh written house and with richie
as a witness it's i don't see
how any reasonable person would convict
god written house however
people who are in fear for their lives
are no longer reasonable correct
so when they're like they're going to
burn your house down they're going to
burn the city down people are going to
be like i don't care about this
people panic gang reason goes out the
window sometimes yeah
i think i think in this case a lot of
people are going to be like he he lives
in
in antioch he's not even in wisconsin
why are we dealing with this why are
they they're going to burn out our city
nah
lock them up it won't work though we saw
you know riot right
protests are going to happen no matter
what you just got to tell these people
no
but too many people are cowards and i
think written house is one that may
start
um a sort of new version of
right-wing populist protests because if
if they put him in prison like this is
this could be anybody's kid okay if your
kid was
you know 17 18 19 years old they're
protecting a shop
they try to do the right thing and
protect themselves somebody shot a gun
that they may have perceived to be at
them and they're being chased by a mob
that could be anybody's kid the guy was
attacking him with escape 100
smash him in the head it's insane it's
insane there's no there's honestly no
argument for this not being self-defense
this is self-defense
in every like this is why we have
self-defense right
well he wasn't he wasn't old enough to
carry a weapon which might be that's
like a misdemeanor sure yeah give him a
misdemeanor but you are allowed to
uh i guess the law is i could be wrong
about wisconsin
if you are a minor and you're in danger
you can pick up a gun from somewhere
else and use it to defend yourself
so uh that's big 10-4 says ethereum gas
fees sucks you have to spend 140 on a
100 transaction
is that true well i don't know not
always he says ada
is with low gas fees and 100
decentralized eth is not decentralized
cardano is the future you need to invite
charles that'd be fantastic
um i know eth isn't decentralized max
was mex kaiser was talking about that
he mentioned that they have reversed
transactions in the past as well
i don't know a lot of all the details
fees suck
i'd love to talk to him uh because it
would be great to have an actual someone
actually in the dev space for
cryptocurrencies to talk about
a lot of what's going on so you know
absolutely uh but if you haven't already
make sure you smash that like button and
you can follow this show
on facebook facebook.comcast irl we post
clips from the show
and you can share them which helps us
leverage facebook's network
to get people to go to timcast.com and
become members so that we can guarantee
that in the event we get banned or
purged or whatever
we are still able to produce content you
can also find us on instagram at tim
cast irl for the same reason comment
like the post all the good stuff
and you can follow me personally at tim
cast we do the show live monday the
friday at 8 pm
we're gonna have a bonus segment up at
about 11 or so
so make sure you subscribe to
timcast.com is there anything you would
like to
shout out robbie absolutely if you want
to volunteer
and help grow this movement so that we
can make america free again
and you know be supportive of candidates
like me who believe in no more wars no
more lockdowns
no more mandates go to freedomforever.us
sign up to be a volunteer you can do it
from any state
and we'll help you connect with
candidates in your area or you can help
in my race
you guys can also follow me ian
crossland.net and ian crosslin across
social media do me a favor go to
timcast.com click the store button and
then buy one of those mugs that say
don't fight an alligator underwater
don't be drawn into their game
if you're gonna fight an alligator which
i don't suggest do it on land do it on
your terms
i love you thank you i love that mug and
i really love talking to people like
robbie it gives me such a great
sense of optimism for the future to see
younger people who are really stepping
up and making it happen
you can follow me on twitter at
sourpatch lids
as i pursue my lifelong dream of having
more followers
i forgot to say follow at robbie
starbucks but that's everywhere yeah
and although uh ian's been very mean to
doge
if you are looking in the chat right now
you will see a link to the doge
to the moon shirt so go to timcast.com
click store
and you will see the to the moon shirt
it's modeled off the iamagrilla shirt
because apparently this is a meme
a theme we're doing now i guess but
instead of a gorilla it's a shiba inu
holding stacks of cash with coins flying
out behind
us to the moon so check that out get it
if you'd like
and we'll see you all over at
timcast.com in about an hour thanks for
hanging out bye guys
you